You ever buddy this episode of the Joe
Rogan experience podcast is brought to
you by hover.
If you were to hover.com
forward slash rogen,
you will get 10 percent off your domain
name registrations.
Hover is a company that I use for my
domain name registrations.
Uh,
it's a,
a very quick,
easy,
clean interface.
You get free who is a domain privacy,
so you don't have to let people know if
you've got some free gas website and you
don't want your mom finding out about
it,
you can hide that shit.
Um,
if you go to [inaudible] dot com forward
slash and again you will get 10 percent
off your domain name registrations.
Go there and check it out.
They're owned by the same people that
own Tang and uh,
there's sort of the same ethic behind
it.
That's they're trying to offer you a
very cool service.
I'm a with a decent price that's not
ripping anybody off and it's something
that we all need if we want to set up
and established websites.
So go there,
check it out.
Um,
it is a,
what are the other things that have to
say about this
and it has a lot of cool,
uh,
options that aren't easily found when
you buy a domain,
like if you go to the,
some of the other guys,
you don't get all these extra bonuses
that this company does,
like a hiding your personal information,
you know,
the security of that,
which is nice because you don't want,
you know,
if you buy a domain,
you don't want everyone to know your
home address.
Yeah,
most of the time usually have to pay for
that stuff.
Yeah.
And again,
it's a,
it's the same company that owns ting.
So,
uh,
we support them,
they support us and it's,
it's a cool company.
So go there,
hover.com
forward slash rogen gave yourself 10
percent off your domain name
registrations freaks.
We're also brought to you by
audible.com.
And if you go to audible.com/Joe,
you will get one free audio book and one
free month of audible service.
Auto Bowl is uh,
an excellent service for use of audio
books.
Um,
I became a big fan of audio books many
years ago.
It's one of the best ways to spend time
where you're forced to sit down and,
you know,
usually it's wasted time whether you're
on a plane or whether you're driving
somewhere stuck in traffic or on a train
or something like that.
Audio books make an amazing companion
and actually make a boring trip.
Enjoyable.
I'm Christopher Ryan,
our friend who is on the podcast again
today,
I believe your book is available.
Um,
sex at dawn is available in audio form.
It was voted one of the best audio books
of 2010 when it came out.
And I actually read the preface,
which is a story of being attacked by a
monkey who,
uh,
who read the book for you,
who reads the other two actors.
There's a female and a male actor who
read,
uh,
because we,
we asked that there be two,
a male and a female voice,
uh,
since it was coauthored with my,
someone's
all into a quality and shit.
Yeah.
It was kind of weird though.
I mean,
the,
the.
Why didn't you read it?
While I offer to.
They wouldn't let him in.
They were like,
no,
thanks.
Anyway,
sons of bitches.
But no thanks.
Um,
yeah,
when you're a first time author you
don't get a lot of respect,
I got to say.
And you know,
the second time around,
it's a whole different thing if the
first book sell.
Yeah,
I would imagine.
Yeah.
But first time around you,
they treat you.
In fact,
I had a dispute with one of the editors
and um,
which ended with her crying and hanging
up on me
and in earlier crying,
there's no crying in publishing
and then she quit.
Yeah,
like within A.
Yeah.
I really made her quit.
Well,
I don't know that it was me or I was the
last straw,
whatever,
but yeah,
it didn't end well.
But an earlier conversation with her,
she was saying something and I said yes,
what they were talking about the cover
art and they had different ideas and I
was like,
well,
you know,
the one you sent me,
it's cool,
but why don't you send me your other
ideas and then we can brainstorm
together.
And she was like,
um,
uh,
no,
we authors can only see one idea.
And I were business partners here.
Why can't I,
I'm,
what does that mean?
Well,
why can't I be involved in this?
And she said,
well,
we can't have the inmates running the
asylum.
Oh Jesus,
you're a prisoner now.
A mental Haas.
And I said,
you know,
I'm a psychologist.
My wife actually does run a mental
hospital or a 32 year old idiot.
So this is that.
What made her quit?
You call her a 32 year old idiot.
I don't know if I use those words,
but that was my implication.
Might have called her a cunt.
I might have,
might have it comes out sometimes
there's moments when it's necessary.
I'm a audible.
Uh,
other than that,
audible has nothing to do with the
Christopher Ryan incident.
No,
they were wonderful except for not
letting me read the whole book.
Sons of bitches.
What's wrong with you people?
But the monkey attacks the most
important part.
Yeah.
And you read that.
I did read that they should do a revised
version.
Let you do it because I generally prefer
except Stephen King,
Stephen King is God damn terrible at
reading his books.
He's so boring.
You know,
when you have an author read the Stephen
King books that become exciting.
There's so much drama and but Stephen
King is so flat.
He's amazing author and one of my
favorite fiction authors,
authors ever.
But uh,
if you get his audio books,
do not get one that's read by him,
but that's my warning to you.
And then we'd go to audible.com
forward slash Joe.
Get yourself a free audio book and 30
free days of service.
That's an excellent company.
I've been using them for almost a decade
now.
I've been using them for a long time so
I can stand up for audible.
They're outstanding.
And again,
they support this podcast and you
already know about [inaudible] dot com.
We don't have to say that today.
Let's just get to Stanley Kripner.
He's driven,
driven all the way here from San
Francisco with Dr Christopher Ryan,
and they even did a podcast along
the way.
They don't give a fuck folks.
They double dip and making things
happen.
Cue The music from flip these.
Get these people going.
Joe Rogan podcast.
That was the weirdest one that caught me
off guard.
And what happened?
I don't know.
I was waiting for her on it,
I guess.
Yeah.
Well we just,
we just rushed through that.
Stanley Kripner.
Thank you very much,
Sir for coming down here.
Pleasure.
And Mr Ryan.
Thank you very much for bringing
Stanley.
When we first did a podcast with Chris,
one of the things he talked about was
you and he said that you're a dear
friend and that if,
if it's possible got to get you on the
podcast.
So here I am so proud.
I'm so honored.
I can't believe you actually bothered to
make the trip all the way down from San
Francisco and do a podcast along the
way.
How can they,
how can people get that podcast that you
guys did along the way?
Well,
I guess,
I guess we'll put it up this week and I,
you know,
we've got a bunch in the pipeline but
we'll just bump everybody else and yet
people can hear us driving down from
Bakersfield on route five complaining
about the cow shit smell
big part of that trip.
Yeah.
That is a weird drive,
right?
It's a weird drive.
I took that drive before the elections
and uh,
that's when you realize a California,
although California is mainly liberal,
there's these pockets where we have
cities where everybody,
you know,
is fairly literate and educated and then
if you spread out towards where they
grow things for some reason those folks
like to believe and nonsense.
And uh,
they had Mitt Romney bumper stickers and
Mitt Romney posters and like,
where am I?
Am I in Idaho or something like that.
What's going on here?
What do you know who met Romney is?
I want to pull over and go,
what's going on?
What is this?
But you know,
that line about Pennsylvania.
I grew up in Pennsylvania and they say
there's Philadelphia on one side,
Pittsburgh on the other side in Alabama.
And
so true,
my parents,
my parents used to live in Wilkes Barre.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
That's,
that's no joke.
That's where people wear camouflage to
the grocery store.
It's total rush limbaugh country.
Well,
there's so many deer out there and you
never know when you're going to have to
duck behind a car and shoot.
Yeah.
Anyway,
tangentially speaking,
that's the name of my podcast.
Anyone wants to check out my extended
conversation with Stanley?
If they had.
I'm sure they won't get enough.
Never enough.
Stanley.
That's Stanley.
What was your,
your name that the Shaman gave you,
your,
your spirit name?
Well,
rolling thunder gave me the name.
Everybody's favorite.
That's everybody's favorite because
everybody,
he talked to me,
but a native American who was not a
shotgun,
um,
who I dedicated this book to add
Richardson gave me the of Costa Wash
Day.
And the best way to translate that is to
use a yiddish term mench.
Oh.
So I thought that was a great either
coming from the first native American
who got a clinical psychology phd in the
country.
Wow.
And that's this gentleman rolling
thunder.
No,
the other guy who we dedicated the book
to,
and regrettably as soon as the book came
out,
he passed over to the advanced age,
so the book is dedicated to him and his
memory and our long friendship over the
years.
Now you are.
I'm one of the few people that is alive
today.
They can say they did ask him with
Timothy leary.
Oh good heavens.
I'm.
I'm sure there are more
people because tim leary to the acid
with a lot of people.
I'm sure there's more,
but the numbers are fairly small.
I would say it's less than one 10th of
one percent of the population,
but you know how it is.
Small numbers can have magnificent
effects in chaos theory.
You have about the butterfly wings
causing the typhoon and Malaysia.
Yeah,
that's what they say,
but that's.
People don't understand.
That's a metaphor.
It's like a lot of stuff in shamanism is
metaphor.
You deal with it at the metaphorical
level than that.
Make sense?
The whole term shamanism is very tricky,
isn't it?
It's.
You say it amongst the respectable
company and they go,
oh,
okay.
You know,
Shamans and what happens with these
shamans do you do go to spirit worlds
and you're like,
well,
yes actually,
and then like,
okay,
and then immediately the conversation
becomes they're talking to a silly
person,
right?
Which is what I talked to
just I don't even use the word spirit
world for one thing to be a mom and you
have to be appointed the Shaman via
community and if the community doesn't
consider you worthy of being a spiritual
leader,
then you don't pass the test and instead
of saying we go to a spirit world,
I say,
well,
Sharma's get knowledge and information
in ways that other members of their
community camp and I just leave it up to
that.
They say,
well,
what ways?
Well,
they get information from their dreams.
They get information by observing
plants,
observing people.
They have a very,
very keen sense of observation and
insight and then that starts to make
sense to them.
Oh,
you mean like a Sarah Apis?
Well,
Shamans were the first therapists
because they mediated problems between
couples.
They did a lot to keep the community
together.
They help people to get better.
If they were sick or if they were
feeling poorly and so they were also the
first physicians of the first doctors
and they used herbs for reason or
another seem to work,
so taking it down to a very practical
level,
you can talk about shamanism and give
them the due respect,
the life that they deserve,
but as a psychologist there's and that's
what you are,
not that many people in that realm of
professional business who accept those
terms.
They use the term Shaman and it's.
That's where it gets tricky,
right?
It gets tricky in that it's almost like
you need a professional word to you
know,
to to replace it with that people are
going to accept in,
in,
in the mainstream.
Actually the word Shaman Commerce from
the field of anthropology and the word
Shaman originated in Siberia.
Nobody knows just win because there were
three different tribes in Siberia that
used words,
some of the Shaman,
but they'll.
Anthropologists began to notice that
spiritual practitioners and other
indigenous societies did pretty much the
same things.
They helped people.
They healed people.
They use their imagination.
They did rituals,
they told myths and narratives,
and so these other people who had their
own words for shaman all got lumped
together by anthropologists using the
term Shaman,
so we're sort of stuck with it and all
that I can say is don't take it that
seriously because each tribe that you
visit has its own word rolling thunder.
For example,
the subject of our book,
the Voice of Rolling Thunder never
called himself a shaman.
He called himself an inter tribal
medicine man because he was able to
learn the medicine systems of five or
six different native American tribes.
He had a whole trailer full of herbs,
hundreds of herbs that I saw them
firsthand and he would take the herbs
that would be most suitable for whoever
he was helping out as he put it,
whoever he was doctoring,
and then of course he did a little
ritual that went along with it.
Now how much of the herbs that he gave
people were actually effective and how
much of it was a placebo.
You know,
this is one of the important ways in
which shamans contributed to the
evolution of the human species.
Obviously some of the herbs were
additional,
obviously some of them were not,
but they work anyway because of the
placebo effect,
but imagine a sick person coming to a
shaman,
the shaman and giving them herbs,
doing a ritual waving or a feather
rattling or rattle banging a drum and
the person for one reason or other gets
well.
Now what about the people that don't get
well?
Those are people that don't have the
imagination,
they don't have the response to the
placebo effect,
and so they die.
What happens when they die?
Their drop out of
the gene pool?
Who is left?
The people who are left,
the people who are able to access their
inner healing ability and passed down
those genes to their descendants and
that's why today we have hypnosis.
We have biofeedback,
we have visual imagery and all of the
other products of mind,
body medicine that work.
The placebo effect highlights a really
fascinating aspect of the human animal.
This,
this ability to heal itself by being
tricked or tricking itself into
believing that it's taking medicine and
then forcing some sort of an effect.
It's very.
It's a very strange and slippery term or
slippery ability and it seems so strange
that the ability to be tricked would be
of evolutionary advantage.
The ability to trick yourself into
thinking you're taking medicine and
healing yourself.
We can't really do that consciously.
We couldn't do it consciously,
but let's go back to evolution.
Rolling Thunder often use the term.
Sometimes you have to trick a person
that they are getting well.
You have to trick a person into using
their own self healing capacity,
their own inner shaman as he put it out.
Now you can use that deliberately.
We have people who are able to hypnotize
themselves,
who are able to get visual images of
their bodies,
mending the bones together and getting
well of the cancer cells shrinking.
This doesn't work for everybody,
but visual imagery as a part of a
holistic program were mainstream
medicine is also used,
can give that extra little edge that can
help a person to get well out.
That little extra edge is a linear
descendant of what Charmin's did some
50,000
years ago.
It's,
uh,
it's interesting the,
the placebo effect in that it,
it,
it's a scientific term,
but yet it's not a very scientific
action.
The action is really sort of mystical in
the ability to heal with the mind and
using the imagination.
It's a very,
very strange thing and it's very strange
and connected with Sherman hasn't begun
shamanism itself.
The idea that these plants contain
information and that especially like
Iowasca,
it's my favorite shamanistic brew just
because of the fact that they had to
figure out over these hundreds of
thousands of different plants in the
Amazon which one contained dmt and which
one contained an Mao inhibitor and
combined the two of them,
if you don't know what that means,
folks,
the DMT,
which is the most potent psychedelic
drug known to man it,
it exists in a bunch of different forms
in nature,
but it's not orally active.
The reason why,
um,
you know,
you could eat grass and you don't get,
you don't have a dmt trip is because
your body produces something called
Monell,
amy and oxidase and monoamine oxidase,
you can inhibit that and you can inhibit
it with natural plants.
Well,
somehow or another in the course of who
went,
who knows how many thousands of years
the Amazon Shaman have had figured out
how to take the vine of one plant in the
leaves of another plant and combine them
together and it was dmt and a natural
Mao inhibitor and that's what.
That's what created Iowasca,
which is an orally active version of
DMT,
the only orally active version that
we're we're aware of and they did it.
They say by talking to the plants and
the plants told them,
yes,
this is discussed in another recent book
of mine,
be mystifying shamanism where we take
all these mysteries of shamanism.
This is a book by Adam Rock and myself,
and we demystify them and cook them into
a psychological terms.
Now what you say about Iowasca is
absolutely correct,
and I've been to the Amazon.
I've taken Iowasca in Brazil,
and that's very powerful.
That's very valuable.
That's a very good teaching tool to the
people down there and even the people
from Western cultures.
And the question comes up,
as you said,
of all of the thousands of plants in the
rain forest,
how did Shamans know how to put these
two plants together?
And I've asked them about that.
They say,
well,
the plant's taught us.
That's good enough for them.
I think that it was a little more
complicated than that.
I think that they watched animals take
plants and as the animals began to turn
on and show unusual behavior,
the shamans began to do that themselves.
Now this doesn't really account for the
combination of the plants,
but maybe they were able to use trial
and effect besides being the first
doctors.
The first psychotherapist Shamans were
the first scientists they used to trial
and the fact they tried out substances
on themselves.
If they worked on themselves,
they turn to other people.
But the genesis of Iowasca is sort of
lost in the mists of prehistory.
And it's a fascinating topic.
And everything that you say about the
Moa inhibitor isn't the DMT is
absolutely correct.
It really is a fascinating topic and
it's such a fragile piece of history
because the shamans are the ones who
understand and know how to make the brew
and they pass this information down from
generation to generation and if they're
gone,
if they're lost and we're losing rain
forest by,
you know,
by the acre,
like literally as we're talking acres
are being dissolved and slowly but
surely these people are getting pushed
out of their natural home and we're
losing the lungs of the earth.
Literally the rain forests are the
lungs,
the earth.
I mean that's
where most of our oxygen comes from and
it's such a fragile thing that we,
we,
we know so little about its origins and
its right there and it's just these few
people that are,
that are living there that,
that truly understand that their
traditions and they've had them passed
down generation to generation.
You used the very same terms at me.
Hell Gorbachev used when I talked with
him.
I wanted him to give me some advice that
I could pass onto an ecology conference.
I was going into Brazil to speak at and
he said,
tell the Brazilians that the lungs of
the earth are the Siberian tiger and the
Amazon rain forest and that the Amazon
rain forest just destroyed one of the
lungs will be destroyed.
Wow.
Now there are Brazilian laws protecting
the rain forest,
but you know,
the Brazilian army,
the Brazilian police can't protect all
of the rain forest and a lot of the
ranchers and lumber companies are just
coming in and slicing up that rain
forest.
Right and left.
I was in southern Brazil with the
Guarani tribe and the Guarani Sharman
invited me to a very sacred ceremony and
that ceremony,
he passed around some brew that I drank
from some stuff that I smoked and other
people also and after around of shall we
say six gourds or pipes of psychoactive
substances.
I was waiting for visions,
but they never arrived and said I could
think very,
very clearly and then he wanted me to
give a prayer and it my best Portuguese,
which I couldn't have done ordinarily.
I said,
yes.
Tell your young people to stop hanging
themselves from the trees because it was
an epidemic of suicide to protest the
destruction of the rain forest.
Wow.
I said,
you met.
Get the young people to be active and
fight the people who are destroying the
rainforest.
Go into politics,
become lawyers.
Fight this to save the rain forest.
And he said,
how did you know our young people were
hanging themselves from the trees?
I says,
well,
I'm a member of the rainforest action
network and San Francisco and we keep
track of what's happening to the rain
forest.
It's very important for us.
It's important for the world in Shamans
like you are way ahead of the game
because you know what will happen if the
rain forests are destroyed.
It's a very.
It's a very fascinating idea that
there's an intelligence to plants and
that these rain forests are networks of
intelligence.
Just that we can't quite tap into it and
that somehow or another during these
altered states you can and then that's
where the information comes to the
Shaman.
Well,
native from both
north and South America use the term in
one language or another.
All our relations and all of our
relations are not wholly human beings,
but the creatures who walk on four legs,
the creatures who crawl on their
bellies,
the creatures who swim in the seas,
the creatures who put their roots into
the ground or who stand tall in the
forest,
all of these are relations.
This is the web of life.
This is the ecosystem,
and you start to destroy that ecosystem
and human beings are not far along the
way in terms of being destroyed
themselves.
Is it a weird
thing that we can't recognize that while
we're doing it,
the human race for some reason is doing
that and can understand what it's doing
to itself.
Doesn't that come back?
So at the end of it,
doesn't that come back to what you were
saying earlier about the placebo effect
and the no cbo effect,
which you know,
a tricking ourselves,
right?
We're tricking ourselves not to notice
that we're tricking ourselves every damn
day.
We're telling ourselves will never die
and so on and so forth.
So and so loves me when you know damn
well she doesn't or whatever it is,
we trick ourselves to make life
tolerable.
Right?
Right.
So within that context,
tricking yourself to heal yourself seems
like it makes perfect sense.
It really does.
It just,
it's,
it's weird that we're able to do.
It's like when you're driving car and
your car is a broken pipe and you see
black smoke come out like that.
I got to get to work and not really
thinking about it.
We,
we,
we somehow or another,
don't feel the impact of the horrible
things that we do in psychology.
We call this denial and people deny
what's right there in front of them
because they have other agendas and
other preoccupations.
This is one reason I was so interested
in rolling thunder and why we wrote the
Book Rolling Thunder,
the Voice of rolling thunder because he
saw all of this 30 years ago.
He saw the global warming.
He saw the destruction of the rain
forest.
She saw the pollution of the earth and
who listened to him.
His audiences listen to them,
that politicians listen to them.
No,
our politicians listing to him now go to
some of the debates in Congress and they
say that global warming is junk science.
Here's massive denial from people who
could make a difference and you take the
polls of what the main concerns are of
the American people.
Concern for the environment is now
number five or six down the list.
Yeah,
that's a weird thing,
isn't it?
Concern for the actual environment is
not at the top of the list of poisoning
of our own earth is not at the top of
the list and could be avoided.
We're human beings are so in ingenuity,
ingenious,
and we have such amazing abilities to
figure out new methods to extract energy
from things.
The fact that we're still relying on
fossil fuels and we're still burning
things and pumping smoke into the air.
Although it does make the best sounding
engines,
it's tough to argue with that at those
goddamn hybrids.
Boy,
anything sucking the soul away from
America.
Sarah,
it's a prius.
Toyota Prius is especially ones with
bumper stickers.
Something about them makes them extra
annoying.
Isn't the plural pre I should be.
They should be illegal,
you know,
you mentioned to all our relations a
cocoa in the,
uh,
in the,
the hardback have sex at dawn.
The first,
what's it called at the beginning,
the preface and know that is an epic.
Ram is like,
to my mother and father,
the dedication,
right?
We dedicated,
it said to all our relations.
I was thinking of this North American,
South American Indian thing,
but a lot of people thought it was
referring to like,
you know,
group sex or something.
All our lovers or something.
Right,
right,
right.
Changed it in the,
in the favor back.
Oh,
that's too bad.
She'd leave that in there.
That's actually cool.
It's a cool thing to say.
Yeah.
You see,
this takes us back to the very first
question you asked.
You think of sharp and Lucy.
Me think of mystical stuff of talking to
spirits.
Know Shamans are very down to earth.
They are concerned with the here and the
now.
There are concerned with the future.
They talk about five,
six,
seven generations in the future.
What is gonna Happen to the Earth in the
future?
There are very,
very practical people.
Now you've done research on dream
telepathy and you've,
uh,
you've actually been cited in scientific
journals and you've been on tv talking
about this stuff,
including the tonight show with Johnny
Carson was at back in the seventies,
back in the day,
the heyday of Johnny Carson.
Did you have a cocktail?
They have cocktails.
Did they smoke cigarettes?
They smoke cigarettes,
right on Johnny Carson show.
Did they smoke cigarettes on the set?
Not when I was there,
no.
Oh,
Johnny didn't smoke.
I thought Johnny was constantly puffing
away.
Yeah.
Know what happened.
I was just doing attorney carson sound.
Oh,
that's Ed.
That's Ed Mcmahon.
Johnny Carson show 'em.
What is dream telepathy?
Well,
this actually goes back to shamanism
because shamans felt that they could
communicate with other Shabas who were
kilometers away,
miles away,
through mental focusing and through
imagination,
through imagery.
Now,
this tradition has come to us through
time and science,
by and large,
didn't take it seriously,
but a small group of scientists called
Paris psychologists devise methods to
put this to a scientific test.
Now to look into dream telepathy,
what we did was to take a soundproof
room,
could a dreamer and the soundproof room
electrodes
to the dreamers head.
Look at the electroencephalograph
machine in those little icicle back and
forth,
rapid eye movements.
We'd wake up the person and asked them
what they were dreaming.
Now at the very same time,
there was one of our staff members and
the distant building and slash,
or a distant room who is looking at a
picture,
usually a famous art print,
some of them by several door valley.
By the way out.
The staff member was trying to project
that image to the dreamer.
The dreamer is trying to reach out and
see that picture and none of them would
transcribe the dreams and then we'd have
a team of dream experts try to match the
dreams with the picture.
After nine or 10 or 11 or 12 sessions
had taken place.
And then you can use statistics to find
out if the matches happen more often by
chance.
Then they would ordinarily.
And much to our surprise,
most of the times they did.
And we did about a dozen different
series.
And about nine of these series,
we're above chance levels,
so we can't say that we have
demonstrated dream telepathy because
sometimes it works,
sometimes it doesn't.
All we can say is that we've made a case
for dream telepathy,
but I think the most important thing we
did was to take green telepathy off the
list of symptoms of mental illness back
when we first started out,
if people said that they dreamed about
the future,
dreamed about what a friend was doing
that got a check mark,
that's a sign of schizophrenia.
That's a sign of delusional thinking no
more.
You take a look at the psychiatric
indices.
That's pretty far down the list.
So I think we made a signal contribution
in terms of letting the
psychotherapeutic world,
especially the psychiatric world,
know that one can make a case that
sometimes dream telepathy does indeed
occur and that the Shamans,
once again,
we were ahead of their time because they
did this as part of their regular
practice thousands of years ago.
The original,
when when people are with the Western
world originally started studying
Iowasca,
one of the things that they wanted to do
was call harming before they had
isolated that it was harming.
They wanted to call it telepathy and
that was the.
That's the name.
They came to it because it gave these
group sort of telepathic.
It gave some sort of an effect that
people were able to communicate in
groups.
Well,
my old friend Alan Ginsburg,
as you know,
was the coauthor of the Ya hey,
papers y'all hate is another word for a
whole Osca.
He and William burroughs wrote these
wonderful letters back and forth and
they experienced telepathy and alums.
Ginsburg went around trying to persuade
her a psychologist,
you know,
use the South American urban your
experiments.
I took him seriously,
but I didn't have a way together.
Nobody else took him seriously and that
experiments still remains to be done.
Now the Iowasca is available now that it
is being used in some experiments or
another one could see if it lives up to
its nickname.
Telepathic.
Yeah,
it's a.
it's fascinating that it was already the
scientific nomenclature was already home
harming for it because it stuck with
telepathy and that was like the actual
scientific word that we use today.
That would be a.
that's a real tricky sort of a slippery
slope of a scientific name for something
that impart some sort of mystical
properties.
Well that's true,
and of course to be properly scientific
one often weeds.
These terms out that are a little too
esoteric or a little bit off the off the
cliff and so we use words like harmony
and harmony into describe dmt to
describe these active ingredients.
It's interesting to think about all the
different names for what we now call
hallucinogenic drugs.
You know,
they were psychotic mimetics there for
awhile and then psychedelics and what
were some of the other three or four?
Actually always liked the word
fantastic.
Hans never caught on,
but the yellow,
they induced fantasy and theologians and
the agenda.
Well No,
I'm theo.
John doesn't work because him,
Theo,
Janice,
finding the God within and a lot of
psychedelics do help people find the God
with them,
but some people take psychedelics for
other purposes,
to have fun,
to enhance sex,
to explore a nature,
don't lose things,
bring the God within out as well.
In my opinion,
they do.
I wouldn't argue with that.
Yeah,
sure.
The,
the idea of dream telepathy in in
mainstream science,
it's got to be something that's very
heavily resisted.
Well,
it is resisted,
but I think that as the years go by,
we're getting a much more intelligence
discussion.
One of my books is called debating
psychic experiences and we have some of
the top pair of psychologists debating
some of the top skeptics in a very
civilized intellectual way back and
forth.
We give the same number of pages to both
the advocates and the counter advocates
and this is a level of discourse that
never would have happened,
but he years ago,
the ultra skeptics never would have sat
down to help write a book with the
proponents of dream telepathy and other
such things.
So at least the discourse is now a
little more civil and the possibility is
now being taken little more seriously.
I don't know what the final outcome is
going to be because I'm an agnostic on a
lot of these issues,
but you know,
I think that this is a human experience
that needs to be explored.
So let's explore it with as many tools
at our disposal as possible.
So do you believe that dream telepathy
is something that occurs occasionally
but cannot be.
It can't be reliably reproduced.
I wish it could be reliably reproduced
because it could be put to practical use
then.
But no.
My belief is it is very unpredictable.
Many things in life are unpredictable.
I sort of compare it to when people my
age have an erection during sex that's
unpredictable.
I wish I could predict it well.
A lot of important things in life,
like erections for older people like
dream telepathy,
like seeing into the future happen,
but they're unpredictable.
That doesn't mean we shouldn't explore
them and study them.
What do you believe are the components
of dream telepathy?
Have you isolated it down to a certain
firing in the synopsis?
Do you mean do you have any idea of what
causes it?
We have the equipment to do much more
with the brain now than we could.
You have to remember the Paris
psychologists don't have very much money
and don't have the tools to a,
uh,
to utilize a lot of this equipment.
But what we did on our studies was very,
very simple.
The nights that the dream telepathy
seemed to be successful were the nights
that the geo magnetic fields of the
earth were very calm,
very few sunspots,
very few electrical storms,
and so one could hypothesize that there
is a field of some sort of global field
were these barely detectable influences
and very subtle means of communication
that can sneak through.
Also,
by and large,
if there is an emotional connection
between the people who are in contact
with each other over a distance,
it's more likely to happen than if
they're complete strangers.
Didn't you have some sort of a crazy
psychic vision of Kennedy being
assassinated?
Well,
actually idea the alphas drain.
My very first psilocybin experience that
I had the courtesy of Timothy leary
who
I went to Harvard to visit and who
invited me to an experiment with
psilocybin.
It was a beautiful and glorious
experience.
It was done during the days when
psilocybin was legal and factors,
one of his last legal psilocybin
sessions and there was only one Downer
during that experience and that was when
I had the actual
vision during psilocybin with my eyes
closed of President Lincoln being shot
and I saw the gun at the base of his
profile and somebody screamed out,
the president has been shot and then
Lincoln space morphed into that of
Kennedy and there was the rifle except
now it was not a pistol,
a rifle and somebody who's screaming.
The president has been shot.
I recorded all of that.
I had such an incredible experience.
I made dozens of copies and sent it to
my close friends and of course in
several months the tragedy of Kennedy's
death actually happened and so my
vision,
whether it was coincidental or
pre-cognitive,
was on record and I considered myself a
highly psychic person.
You don't consider yourself know
exactly.
Did that freak you out at all?
No,
nothing freaks me out in this field.
It's just a surprise that sometimes
leaves me as a sense of longer because
there's more things going on in the
world that we,
uh,
don't take seriously or that take us by
surprise.
But,
um,
the thing that really freaks me out is
when people do not take global warming
seriously,
the thing that freaks me out as well,
mainstream religions in the world don't
give women proper rights to control
their own bodies.
The thing that freaks me out is when
politicians fight each other,
leaving the children of the world,
especially in the Middle East with
nightmares and posttraumatic stress
disorder.
Those are practical things that I've
written about.
And those are the things that freaked me
out.
Yeah,
I think that freaks out anybody with a
conscience or anyone.
He's paying attention to the,
the evils of this world.
We live.
We live in very strange times where we
have so much information,
more access to information than any
generation ever,
but yet things more or less are still
going along the same course as far as
global events as far as,
uh,
the monopolization of natural resources
as far as you know,
using the bore to monopolize those
natural resources.
It seems to be the same as it's ever
been.
It's a little better.
Back when I first became interested in
posttraumatic stress disorder,
I've written three books on that topic
that your listeners can find on Amazon
calm.
There were 30 wars going on in the
world,
most of them civil wars.
Now there's 20 wars.
That's an improvement.
Yeah,
I guess there are still are a couple of
billion people who are displaced in the
refugee camps.
There still are children who have
nightmares every night because they're
living in war zones or still are women
being raped and brutalized,
but things are a little better than they
were 30 years ago.
Well,
things are a little better than there
were thousands of years ago,
that's for sure.
I've had this conversation recently
where a friend were talking about how
thousands of years ago,
if some people up from
another land,
like they were there to rape and
pillage.
Now when people show up,
they're a part of the global economy.
They're tourists and you know,
we allow them in even if they don't
speak the language and we sell books,
tell,
tell them where the restaurants are,
try to speak English to them to get
their money.
You know,
the world has changed drastically in
that respect,
but yet,
you know,
there's still a lot of really fucked up
things about the way human beings
behave.
Well,
that was my friend Buckminster Fuller's
concept of the global village and
Buckminster Fuller had a plan,
a logistical plan to feed everybody in
the world.
If the wars would stop.
Now that vision is still applicable,
but it's not going to happen as long as
these 20 wars are going on and food is
unable to go from areas of plenty to
areas of poverty.
So the conflicts and the wars,
not only in the middle of the east but
in Africa and even in our own country in
terms of the,
in terms of the terrorists,
the home bread,
terrorists who are victimizing people in
the United States as long as others
going on,
we still aren't going to have the global
village that Buckminster Fuller digital.
Yeah.
The Utopian concept is a really
interesting one.
The idea of the global village,
I've always felt like one way to make it
happen would be to take these people
that are profiting off of rebuilding
these countries after we blow them up in
like and make it profitable to rebuild
ghettos,
make it profitable to go to companies
and educate kids,
make it profitable to,
to fix their water systems and provide
them with sewage and you know,
and make sure that they can take care of
themselves,
bring food and medicine.
And it seems like there's money involved
in that.
It seems like it's just a matter of
transferring the energy to instead of
only doing it to come to countries where
we blow them up,
let's do it.
The countries that need it,
like make it profitable for countries
like or companies like Halliburton to
make money by building up third world
countries.
Halliburton made over $2,000,000,000
from the Iraq war and a lot of that was
lost during graft and corruption.
Now while this Halliburton Dong to
improve the infrastructure in the United
States,
our country is literally falling apart,
especially in terms of transportation,
especially in terms of cleaning up the
pollution in our country.
Dwight Eisenhower was actually the last
precedent that paid attention to the
infrastructure with this interstate
highway system.
A Bama is trying to do something for the
infrastructure right now,
but he's not having much success in
getting that through congress.
You are absolutely right.
If some subsidy could be given to big
companies to build up the infrastructure
in the low income parts
of our country to clean up the polluted
streams and waters and oceans and
rivers,
that would be money well spent.
It just thinking about what we're doing
with corn.
You know the amount of money in the
amount of emphasis they put on on on
farmers,
growing corn and the subsidies that are
involved in that.
It's pretty staggering and that's the
reason why there's so much corn syrup
and corn and corn that corn is fucking
terrible
for you and that's why people are
getting obese because if they're taking
all of the sweetening from the corn
syrup and look at all the subsidies that
are going to correlate,
there are many natural sweeteners that
do not add weight.
Some of them come from China,
some of them actually can come to the
United States.
Why don't we have more money going into
those natural sweeteners rather than the
sweeteners like aspartame for example,
that Donald Rumsfeld made money off and
which is worse for you than the sugar in
soft drinks
supposedly.
Yeah.
I've never heard anybody really get
fucked up from aspartame,
but I've read terrible things about
potential side effects.
Yes.
But it's so delicious.
And a diet coke,
that's where it's problematic.
Um,
I like Stevia.
Stevia is good stuff.
Steve was good stuff.
Yes.
So go along with that.
Great.
Although I have read recently some
negative things on Stevia,
but someone said that's propaganda and I
haven't looked into it.
Well,
of course,
because the competitors are going to
spread nasty things about something
that's healthy.
Yeah.
The,
the idea that someone can come along and
have some natural sweetener that doesn't
put any calories into,
uh,
into your food and it's actually
healthy.
It's very dangerous for the,
for the established elite.
I'm going to go back to rolling thunder
because in our book,
the Voice of Rolling Thunder,
there's a long interview with him about
how he did not pay attention to taking
sugar into his body and how he got
diabetes and he goes on a long harangue
trying to urge people to stay away from
sugary drinks,
sugary treats,
or they'll end up getting diabetes like
he did and his diabetes was so bad that
Mickey Hart of the grateful dead and I
had to fly to his home in the data and
get him into an airplane.
Bring him back to Mickey Hart's Doctor
in the San Francisco area who had to
amputate his leg to save his life from
diabetes.
And this is all from just eating sugar
or is that there's some sort of,
uh,
does he have a natural inclination?
Oh yeah.
She'll know diabetes as something that
it's ordinary for people to gather.
They reach a certain age,
but there was a genetic proclivity along
with that.
But he learned his lesson and toward the
end of his life he tried to warn people
about eating more healthy food,
less sugar.
By the way,
Stan,
while you're talking about a rolling
thunders genetics,
you might mention your coauthor of the
book.
The coauthor of a book is shitty
enrolling city and Morning Star and city
and morning star is the ground son of
rolling thunder.
And he and I got together and we
interviewed two dozen people who knew
rolling thunder and told their stories
in the book that we called the Voice of
Rolling Thunder because Mickey Hart,
the drummer of the grateful dead,
his recorded several dozen speeches of
rolling thunder over the years.
And we got access to those tapes.
And so we actually have the first
original speeches laced through the
book.
And so we actually do have the voiceover
length under,
in the book is.
There's no audio book though,
is there?
Oh,
we are hoping there will be an old.com.
Let's get on that.
Yeah,
you've got the original tapes there.
That's fantastic.
That's amazing.
Um,
you,
you were very fortunate enough to see
the,
a psychedelic hysteria of the sixties
and see it manifested in,
in law in was in 1970.
This sweeping it's schedule one
psychedelic act that was passed.
What was the impact on culture?
I've always found it was one of the most
fascinating areas for this country and
even humanity that we can study the,
the,
the distance between the fifties and the
sixties.
Like there's never been a time that we
could ever look at where there's been
such a gigantic radical change that you
can really attribute a big part of it to
psychedelics in this country.
Yes.
And also psychedelics of course,
should be put down by the political
establishment today,
but without the psychedelics,
you would have had the,
uh,
smart investors who are responsible for
the intranet,
for the cell phone,
for the smartphone,
for computers,
etc.
Etc.
Dna replication.
I mEt carrie mullis a couple of weeks
ago at ted.
He won the nobel prize in chemistry for
coming up with the pca.
Yeah,
exactly.
Kary mullis mollison.
He gives Due credit to his work with
lsd.
I met fraNcis crick And he gives you
credit for his lsd sessions for the
double helix.
So there are many adventures outside of
the electronics that made changes,
much less the difference in style,
the difference in music,
the difference in sexual behavior.
And historians when they write about
that area,
do not really give enough credit to what
the psychedelics did in the role that
they played.
No,
they don't do that.
it's a,
it's a weird thing.
So they try to avoid it.
They try to avoid it because they're
afraid it will get censored.
And often a musket censored.
I know of cases where journalists
written about the role of lsd and other
psychedelics and social change in their
editors.
Have a whiteboard that out of the
article and I'll put the article young
without due credit to lsd.
Now you don't get this at all,
the alternative press and you certainly
don't get this in the show such as
yours,
which are for a wheel and don't have
censorship involved with them,
but of course I saw all of this
firsthand.
I knew Albert Hoffman.
He was a very dear friend of mine.
He should have won the nobel prize and
he would have if lsd had been allowed to
take its aCtual course and help people
in psychotherapy and creativity of dying
and dignified death,
but lsd fell into the wrong hands that
was victiMized by the government and
poor Albert Hoffman was very grieved by
this.
He wasn't grief for not getting enough
honor himself,
but he had a tool here that could be
very,
very helpful to people.
And then you had the extremists.
Like my old friend timothy leary,
who I liked very much,
but who I disagreed with going to one
extreme and saying lsd for all.
And then the government on the other
hand saying lsd for nobody.
It's a dangerous thing.
And people like Richard Nixon,
he's saying timothy leary is public
enemy number one,
the most dangerous man in America.
And where was the middle ground?
People like Jean Houston,
robert masters,
sydney colon osher,
yannick [inaudible],
some of the pioneers who I knew very
well of that era.
There were cop completely eclipsed and
they were cut off from legit have the
supplies of lsd.
The work with lsd.
The work that uh,
francis crick did with the double helix
dna.
That's very controversial,
isn't,
it?
Wasn't that on his deathbed that he said
that he,
uh,
he come to these conclusions was very
old.
This is actually after I met him
when he talked about lsd.
And of course we don't know the role
that,
that actually played in something as
complicated as The double helix.
Remember tHat his parked or watson
deserves equal credit.
We never know how much credit to give to
somethiNg like that and it's a source.
It's a source of a creative person will
try many things.
Um,
I interviewed track zappa for an article
I wrote about the influence of
psychedelics on art and music and he
says,
I don't know what role psychedelics
played with my music and artist and
musician will go to many sources and
we'll pull from life experiences for
many sources.
And so no,
you never know exactly all we can say.
It didn't seem to do with any herb.
The harm francis crick.
Did he tell you himself that he had.
No,
this was after I met him.
After he met him,
we had a full conversation,
but
this was years after I met him that he
made the statement about lsd because a
michio kaku wouldn't admit that I had a
conversation with him on the opiod
anthony show and I asked him about
francis crick and he completely poopooed
instead.
It's nonsense and he's of the belief
that psychedelics are bad for the brain
and give you brain damage.
Really kind of a disappointing point of
view when I,
when I talked to him because I,
I recognized right away that he had
never had any experiences with them
himself.
It was just purely a,
a standard sort of academic.
And uh,
he didn't believe it at all.
He said that it was not true in the
newspaper this morning.
There was a statistic though,
the within the last 12 months,
170,000
people have died from prescription
drugs.
Okay.
How many people have died in the last 12
months from marijuana?
months from an overdose of lsd?
Yeah.
it's ridiculous because it's also when
you are a mainstream academic,
like a guy like michio kaku,
you almost have to talk bad about
marijuana and illegal drugs and you
almost have to ignore the dangers of
PresCription drugs.
It's reAlly not something that you have,
there's,
there's no benefit in,
in his career toward,
for him taking a controversial.
Yeah.
But you know that that's like
halliburton.
That's like some executive at
Yeah.
You know,
it's like you can stand up and say the
truth,
especially these days is you and I were
talking about the other day,
you know,
the internet has changed the whole
communication and the gatekeepers
getting edged out of the picture.
I mean,
andrew weil who's a mutual friend of
stanley and me,
uh,
you know what I'm talking about,
a medical doctor,
a,
he was the guy with the white.
Exactly.
Yeah.
It's on the cover of time magazine and
all this,
right?
His first three or four booKs are all
about consciousness and he very openly
talks about his use of Mushrooms and
iowasca and you know,
he's ecstasy and he's done all these
things that he talks about,
his experience he took and he's very
balanced.
The dudes harvard Med school,
residency at mass general national
institute of health,
like top,
top,
top.
And I interviewed him a few months ago
and so he's like.
And I said to tHem,
I really admire the fact that you've
never run away from that and you never
said,
oh,
I was young and stupid.
Like,
no,
the dude is very courageous about it.
And hey,
his career is doing fine.
Terence mckenna had a great quote about
psychedelics that he said that
oftentimes people are doing the work for
the man and that you're worried about
the man and in worrying about the man
you actually doing the work of the man
himself.
Right.
You know,
being that you're censoring yourself and
that you really,
you don't have to censor yourself nearly
as much.
You know,
I,
I'm in a weird field.
I'm a standup comedian,
but I'm also a sports commentator.
I do the commentary for the uLtimate
fighting championShip anD it's on fox tv
and it's on know fx.
It's on the paper view and it's a,
it's a multibillion dollar business,
but I'm very open about psychedelics and
I'm very open about the positive aspects
oF them that I've experienced myself and
I've been very fortunate that I've had
other jobs like standup comedy to always
fall back on that I never needed to
worry about censoring myself and I never
saw.
I never thought about it,
but I've experienCed a lot of
frustration from various people from
agents and producers and executives were
there.
Like what are you doing?
Like what are you thinking that this is
going to hurt the big picture.
This is going to hurt the package is
going to hurt the things that I'm
connected to.
It never has.
It never has never got pressure from fox
or anybody don't know.
Well,
you know what?
Here's the thing.
Debate me,
sit down,
sit down with me and let's discuss what
is,
what is the real issue that,
that's a problem here.
Is it illegality?
Well,
do you understand the roots of the
illegality?
Because it's not based on science.
It's based on hysteria.
It's based on worry.
It's based on fear is racism,
but surely when you talk about
marijuana,
it propaganda and,
and really,
uh,
it was uh,
based on the suppression of hemp as a
commodity really didn't even have
anything to do with marijuana as a
psychoactive drug.
So anybody who wants to sit down and
debate with me,
you're just gonna reinforce my point.
I've talked about this and I've read too
much about this to,
to,
to step back.
It's,
it seems to me,
and he will be able to speak on this
because you've seen this happen,
you were there from the fifties and
sixties that the psychedelics,
the change that psychedelics can impart
human beings,
aLthough I think anything can be abuSeD.
I mean,
I think any humans have a propensity to
overindulge in almost any sort of
behavior,
positive,
ordinary people get addicted to love.
I mean,
people can get obsessed with
relationships that could,
you know,
under the control of someone with
discipline or with the,
you know,
someone who has a grip on reality.
It could be a great thing.
We,
we have this ability to fuck any out.
but overall I think psychedelics have an
incredibly positive effect on people
overall.
You know,
if you look at the broad spectrum of
users and talk about johns hopkins had a
recent paper that they published about
the longterm effects of suicide in use
in,
um,
these people that took it were enhanced
the personality 20 years later.
One mushroom trip,
right?
Yes.
This is one reason why I'm glad that I
am in mainstream academia.
I don't have to worry about these
things.
I teach at saybrook university,
which is very open minded,
which allows people to do their
dissertations on iowasca,
on lsd,
even on telepathy and we're completely
accredited.
Prehistoric sexuality.
YeS.
Chris ryan is one of our most
distinguished graduates and wrote his
dissertation on sexuality.
Saybrook university
is where whereas san francisco
online university,
people from all over the world can get
them to credited master's or doctor's
degree by doing work through their
computer,
through the internet,
through skype and half person to person
conversations with me and other faculty
members
should have left san francisco.
San francisco is the free capital of
this country.
Always will be.
Well,
it's kinda,
you know,
and it gets back to your point about
the,
the cultural effect of psychedelics in
the sixties,
right.
It san francisco is the place that's
still vibrating a little bit
from this.
It's still ringing.
The gong still has the,
the.
I lived in san francisco from the time
when I was 11 until I was 13,
or actually,
excuse me,
seven to 11.
Um,
and uh,
it was a fascinating time because it was
a,
when the Vietnam war was ending and a
san francisco was unlike any other place
in the country.
I didn't know it at the time,
of course,
because I was only seven years old,
but we went from New Jersey,
which was this barbaric shithole to san
francisco and then went from san
francisco to Florida,
which was another barbaric shit.
All.
So it was,
it was really interesting.
I didn't know what the word nigger meant
until I was 11 years old.
I didn't,
I never heard it.
I've never heard in san francisco.
I mean the people don't believe that,
but there was,
I didn't experience racism.
I went to school with black kids,
asian kids.
everybody was just a kid.
Oh,
this is bobby.
His family's from Korea.
This is mike.
His family is black.
There was no,
there was no a weirdness to it until I
went to Florida.
And then my mother didn't believe me.
I asked,
I said to my mother,
I said,
mom,
what is nigger mean?
And she said,
you know what it means?
And I go,
no,
I don't know what it means.
Like,
you know,
my mother grew up in New Jersey,
she probably heard it all the time,
but when we lived in Florida it was the
first time I'd heard it in school and I
had to come to her and that she's like,
it's a derogatory term for black people.
And I was like,
what?
I was so shocked because from age seven
to 11,
I grew up in this really open minded,
intelligent environment.
You know,
we,
we lived near a lombard street.
We were like in the heart of san
francisco,
gay neighbors like gay to me.
And was like,
oh,
that guy's gay,
this guy's tall.
You know?
It was like,
it was just a part of life.
San francisco is a just an amazing,
amazing spot.
Yeah.
I love san francisco.
You know,
I want to hear more about your life.
Every time I come on here,
we're talking about me.
In this case,
we're talking about stanley,
which definitely is entry,
but I got to get you on my part.
We got plenty of time.
I'll do it every year.
More than happy.
Yeah.
My story is a weird one.
it's very strange,
but I'm the.
One of the coolest things about the
story is this,
the podcast,
the ability to have a guy like you on
have a conversation for hours at a time.
What was it like?
Did you.
Were you living in san francisco during
the sixties?
no,
I was doing the dream telepathy research
in New York city with my mom,
these medical center during the 19 six
years,
but once I met becky hart,
I would take a trip to san francisco a
couple of times.
You're in stay at his ranch and rolling
thunder as well as all other members of
the grateful dead and the other members
of the rock community.
Now they got a tour of haight ashbury,
had friends in haight ashbury,
so every time I came to san francisco I
got myself immersed in the hippie
culture.
The psychedelic culture.
LeArned a lot.
Came back to New York city,
put that knowledge to use in the
research that we were doing,
and then we actually ran out of money.
I couldn't do the dream telepathy
research anymore,
but I got an offer to teach at saybrook
university and that's when I moved to
san francisco in the,
uh,
in the early 19 seventies.
So you moved there right after
everything became illegal?
Yes.
That is correct.
what was the effect on san francisco?
the,
uh,
the change from.
Well,
the effect was sort of negative.
I'll know.
I saw a lot of people who had been
dabbling with psychedelics and then they
switched to cocaine.
Some of them switched to heroin and so
the illegality had some very negative
effect upon a lot of young people.
Again,
not to say that they shouldn't have the
responsibility was there,
their decision to turn to these harder
drugs.
But uh,
the beautiful summer of love didn't last
very long.
if I don't want to screw up everything,
you know,
um,
as one of the.
Did you know terence mckenna at all?
Yes,
I did.
One of the other things that he said
that I found really fascinating was that
what we really learned from the,
the sweeping psychedelic act of 1970
when they just made everything illegal
was how easy it was,
at least at the time to throw water on
this revolution,
this revolution from.
I always use buddy holly and jimi
hendrix as an example.
I'm like,
buddy holly was like a rebel in the
fifties,
you know,
pig,
cu.
You know why I feel blue.
It's like so calm and then you go from
that to voodoo child,
you know?
I mean early beatles too late beetle.
Yeah.
Very good one to hold your hand to fly
on the wall.
Risk of.
Well,
you know,
I have a daughter.
One of my daughters is 16 and she's,
um,
she's really into the beatles.
It's just sheer boyfriends.
Was that time to be dead?
I'm nice.
I'm easy.
I,
you know,
my feeling is boys like girls and girls
like boys and if you're nice to them to
seek out,
I don't mind them.
I don't,
I really don't.
I just,
I don't have an attitude that there's
something wrong with two kids making out
or doing whatever they do.
I guess I don't think there's anything
wrong with it.
I liked it and remember when I was 16,
my girlfriend liked it.
It's like it's normal.
I mean it's uh,
it's certainly awkward and strange,
but I'm not a scary dad to me at all.
I'm very friendly.
But um,
she's a,
she's an interesting kid and she's in
love with the beatles and I'm.
One of the things at her and I've been
talking about was the difference between
the beatles early stuff and then like
the white album,
like what this radical transformation
and that this came about a lot of it
because of their fascination with
altered states of consciousness and then
eastern religions which came directly
out of that.
Yeah,
it's a real problem with the beatles
though is highlighted by my good friend
bill per,
and that's fucking yoko ono.
how did that.
She is like the one,
like if you wanted to say maybe acid is
bad for you,
what the fuck john?
like what were you thinking?
Man?
I was just talking to my mom,
yeah,
about this and I didn't know that.
Like everyone hated yoko at time.
Like I always thought everyone liked
yoga,
you know back then,
but no,
everyone hated the back.
see,
that's the key to it because because he
was such an original thinker,
the fact that everyone was saying,
john,
you're wrong.
Just makes him say fuck you.
You want to see something cool.
Pull up the video with bill burr on yoko
ono.
I'm going to bring my friend bill
burroughs on tuesday.
Yeah,
one of the funniest guys in the world.
Really,
really hilarious comedian,
but he was also a huge beatles fan and a
huge chuck berry fan and one time john
lennon got to play with chuck berry on
television and John Lynn and brought
yoko ono with him to play as well,
and she sabotaged the entire
performance.
He started like screamiNg into the mic
and bill berg goes absolutely crazy
about this and highlights and it's.
It's,
it's one of my favorite videos on the
internet when it comes to music and here
I will play it for you right now
as much as people talk about the beatles
and how great their music is was
whatever you want to say.
I totally agree with them.
I think that the greatest band of all
time,
but I have to be honest with you.
John lennon and paul mccartney redefined
pussy whipped.
You have to watch this fucking video.
It's john lennon is singing with chuck
berry.
Chuck berry is probably one of the main
reasons why john lennon,
lennon ever picked up a guitar,
so now he's on tv.
he gets to play with his idol.
They're playIng a chuck berry's hit
memphis.
Okay.
John lennon's got yoko in his fucking
band there in the middle of singing this
song on television and they're killing
it.
It's going great.
Yoko's playing some stupid fucking drunk
even though she has no talent
whatsoever.
He's putting her in the fucking band.
Just she'll,
she'll shut the fuck up and stop nagging
me.
too much of a fucking pussy to tell her
that she has.
No,
no.
All right,
the only reason why you're here yoko's
because you're sucking my dick.
All right.
No,
you can't play the bongos.
But anyway,
she's up there playing the bongos,
right?
John lennon,
chuck berry,
two of the greats of all time
harmonizing singing this hit from the 19
fifties.
That's what this moment's above.
And yoko in the middle of it can handle
that.
She's not getting any shine.
She takes the fucking microphone out of
the stand,
starts playing the bongo and as this
thing and you know,
go go johnny go.
Whatever.
She picks up the mic and I swear to god
goes some fucking crazy shit.
And you see open as wide as they are and
it's that.
It's that fucking look like a buddy of
yours.
And he's,
he's,
he's dating some fucking psycho,
but he's in love with her so you can't
fucking say anything and you're just
sitting there waiting for the fucking
lightning bolt to hit your friend in the
head where he finally realizes that he's
dating a psycho chuck berry.
BuT that's what the fuck she did.
And chuck berry's like,
what the fuck?
And it's kinda like john,
that's your woman get her in line and
john lennon does not even fucking,
he doesn't even blink.
He just,
he just keeps playing and then she does
it again later on in that song.
And then you look at all the other
musicians and they just keep playing the
song like yoko isn't even fucking there.
And uh,
I actually get infuriated when I watched
this video.
The fact that john didn't just stop
playing in that moment and what he
should have done was dressed or down
right there.
Yes.
I find you want to have a fucking
moment.
This is your mom.
If you ever fucking do that again.
I was slacking.
So fucking heart and the head.
Your eyes are going to look like mine.
You understand me?
You play that fucking buying.
When you shut your face,
you bitch.
You crawled out of the fucking well and
ring.
You understand me?
I don't mean to.
Why I'm fucking.
You are going to be fucking anybody.
You can't play the punk bongos.
You can't say shut your fucking face.
and then he just walks back up to the
mic.
And just counts the band back in,
right?
Is that what the fuck he should've done.
There's no perfect people.
That's what it is.
We have to accept that all of our idols
are flawed.
And even the great john lennon,
beautiful musician and powerful cultural
figure as he was,
had terrible tasting lemon.
Well I happen to like yoko ono's are.
How dare you.
How dare you sir?
Hers of mom.
I and I thought it was extremely
original and very provocative.
now I don't like what she did with the
chuck berry.
John lennon do wet.
She was not completely without tell.
I went to see the yoko ono art exhibit
when I lived in boston and one of the
things that she had was a block of wood
with nails in it and a bag of nails and
a hammer and she encouraged to
participate in her art and that's what
she wanted to do when you walk by,
just pick up a nail and and whack it in.
And that was art and what I had the joke
was if she really wanted to encourage
people to participate,
she should take the nails and put them
in her forehead and there'll be a
fucking line around the block.
It would be like that scene from
airplane with a nun,
with the guitar and boxing gloves.
Everybody will be winding up.
It take a slam and one of those dumb
nails.
But I should also mention that I had the
great fortune of hearing the beatles at
their shea stadium concerts,
I should say.
I saw the beatles because you couldn't
hear a word they were saying there were
so much screaming from their fans.
Oh wow.
And so I also use the beatles in some of
my articles about the influence of
psychedelics on art and music.
And you're absolutely rIght.
They did make a switch thanks to
psychedelics there work with the
maharishi,
the influence of eastern religions.
George harrison taking up the guitar,
you know,
like musicians.
They changed the.
Have they evolved sometimes for the
better sometimes for the worse.
But I think in the beatles case,
they were venturing into new and
unexplored territory.
They were two artists,
you know,
they were really expanding and they
weren't worried about,
you know,
sticking to their sound,
whether it's their acdc sort of riff
like,
you know,
the signature rifts and acdc.
I love acdc,
but damn,
he can hurt here an acdc sign a mile
away.
Once you hear it,
you know,
it's an acdc song.
The beatles really,
really went out there and they took a
lot of,
like really crazy chances with some of
their stuff.
Yes,
I did.
And I met rolling thunder through mickey
hart of the grateful dead because
rolling thunder song was living in the
haight ashbury and he nuts.
Some of the grateful dead.
And when his father rolling thunder came
to town,
he made the connection.
This is all told about our book,
the voice of rolling thunder.
And that is how rolling thunder got to
meet bob dylan and participated in the
rolling thunder review.
And so there's a lot of rock and roll
stuff that's part of the rolling thunder
legends
yesterday in the car in stanley.
And I were talking about some of the
musicians he's known over the years and
he mentioned that hendrix was opening
for the monkees.
Whoa,
you are talking about getting blown up
the stage.
Take my stepchildren to hear the monkeys
because they loved the monkeys and jimi
hendrix opened for the monkeys and I
told them he is going to be a major rock
and roll star.
Never forget that name.
And they didn't.
And a few years later the monkeys were
forgotten.
And jimi hendrix was a classic poor
monkeys.
Yeah.
They didn't do so badly.
They each went onto their own career.
They,
you know,
found please.
No big deal.
I mean they were fine.
They were cute.
I like the monkeys.
When I was a little kid,
one of the first,
a fake bands.
They were like the first boy band.
Really essentially the manufactured boy
band.
Now when you see like the,
the,
you know,
back in the day where it was the beatles
and you know,
and elvis and they,
that was the teeny bopper thing.
And now you see like justin bieber,
isn't that sort of a sign of the times,
you know that that's the teeny bopper
now it's Like the,
the teeny bopper is an 18 year old that
looks like a 12 year old girl.
Yeah,
girl.
He's looking for any sings like a girl,
you know,
it's,
it's very odd.
Like wow,
we're in this really strange time of
almost like a suspended adolescent
suspended childhood.
Like they want to contain it and carry
it and he sort of the ideal spokesperson
for that.
And I wonder,
I don't know enough about the history of
fashion and so on to know whether this
is true or not.
But it seems like since the late
eighties,
nineties,
somewhere we started like circling in
terms of fashion,
right?
Like disco came back,
you know,
and very briefly,
pat bell bottoms,
barely.
They tried to come back to.
Yeah.
But it seems,
doesn't,
it sort of feels like,
like we've come to the end of the line
in some way.
So now they're trying to circle around
and reduce stuff.
Oh,
there's nothing new under the sun.
You know what's old today is new
tomorrow and this is just part of the
fashion cycle that's been happening for
centuries.
I think that what's most interesting and
even a little bit dangerous as the
prolonging of adolescents with adults,
right?
Adults who are acting like they're
teenagers.
I don't Have any problem with justin
bieber or any of the teeny bopper,
favorites yellow,
that's their thing and they're welcome
to do it,
but when adults start to act like
teenagers and start acting out and start
to behave irresponsibly,
I think this is where people really have
to grow up,
especially with all of the crises in the
country and the crises in the world,
like what do you.
What examples to use like adults acting
like teenagers
years.
I think that there is a tendency for
some adults to look at theIr kids as
pals and say,
oh,
my daughter is my best friend.
I'm her best friend.
Well,
this is nonsense.
You're the mother.
You're not the best friend of your
daughter.
You lay down the rules,
you give them instructions.
You teach your daughter how to become an
adult.
You teach moral codes.
You teach rules,
you teach regulations,
you serve as a role model.
What's this best friends?
Crap,
all of them.
You can't be both.
You can be a best friend as well as a
role model.
Someone who lays down.
I would not say never.
All that I could say is that role
confusion is not really part of parents.
What about when you see like a man in
his thirties and he sagging his pants?
Have you witnessed that?
Yes.
How about that?
Is that the weirdest thing ever?
You've seen some shit and your day.
Just the sagging pants thing really
makes me worry about the future of
humanity.
Grown men,
grown men that are probably going to
have babies of their own.
See this justin?
Nothing wrong with this.
Polo except for a stupid baggy pants
sagging and you understand that.
Burn,
that sagging.
Is that what that is?
Yeah,
they all sag thai fishing with justin
bieber having saggy pants.
I have troubLe with grown men having
Saggy pants trying to be teenagers.
What the fuck is that about?
I know a Dude,
he's.
I love him to death,
but wheN he was like 39,
he starts sagging his pants.
I was like,
come on son,
and that's just when you need something
to hold your balls up.
Anyway.
Yeah.
That's when they start going.
Maybe that's what it is.
You just didn't want the tickle.
The parents hitting the base of his
balls as his balls dropped.
He tried to compensate.
It's like a comb over with his pants
were silly and I think,
uh,
there's a,
there's a prolonged silliness or from
the seventies to today,
but I think that what's going on today,
over the last decade or so as I think
that even though there's still plenty of
silliness,
like justin bieber,
and again,
I have nothing against justin.
He's a child and he makes music for
other children and you know,
who knows,
maybe one day from now we'll look back
and say,
well,
this was when justin bieber was a child.
Now look,
he's this brilliant adult musician
making this really cool shit and are
sure.
Yeah,
happened to ricky martin.
He was part of the noodle.
This boy's bound from puerto rico.
Who would have guessed that he would
become a broadway star and a brilliant
broadway
is easy on broadway now.
Yeah.
She just said les miserables.
He is an a and I saw him in las vegas.
One of the best acts I've ever seen in
las vegas.
She's a marvelous musician.
He's gotten rave reviews for his role in
a bed where he plays shake lavar of all
people.
Stem kripner,
ricky martin fan.
Absolutely.
Now you know,
he's full of stuff,
right?
You live in la vida loca.
I just want to know.
Oh,
absolutely.
Great to live in love.
You know,
he's a talented guy.
Nothing wrong with that,
you know.
And uh,
and finally out of the closet too,
I think that's another,
another beautiful thing that.
Well he's commanded for that.
And lady gaga who I also like,
she has born that wave that probably
saved the life of dozens of gay and
lesbian kids.
Yeah.
That's a sad,
sad,
sad thing about this world is that
that's still an issue.
You know,
in the wild is gay marriage debate is
going on.
You know,
who knows what kind of creepy shit
getting passed through congress.
It's not even getting public
recognition.
Everybody's paying attention to whether
or not people should have the right to
do whatever they want sexually with
someone who also wants to do with them.
So it's a strange thing that I always
sort of say it's like,
it's almost like a cultural beach ball.
You know,
if you're in a concert and someone
throws a beach ball and it goes up and
comes down,
like,
you know,
it's like nothing ever fucking happened.
It just kind of gets tossed around.
Like,
what do you think about gay marriage?
You know,
just like,
oh no,
what do affirmative action and nothing
ever gets fixed,
but they just get sort of tossed around
back and forth.
whenever this.
I'm going to go back to sharmane because
in shamanic traditions around the world,
what we would call gay and lesbian
people were given a great deal of honor.
Many of them became dancers,
singers,
even shamans and native americans.
Not 100 percent,
but most native americans said,
look,
here's somebody who acts like a woman
likes members of his own gender or her
own gender.
Depending on which one you're talking
about,
the great spirit must have devoted some
very special time to making them that
way,
so we have to give them special honor
and respect them.
Now the europeans came in,
oh,
that's terrible.
Let's get the inquisition on them,
and they killed what we would call gays
and lesbians.
They killed shamans.
They killed them sometimes very,
very brutally,
and at the same time,
the europeans gave much less power to
women than the native americans did.
Native americans gave a lot of power to
women in their governing councils,
in their decision making and in their
families.
Yeah.
Nowhere american came over.
The europeans came over and storm the
place because checks were running
everything.
Yeah.
that's the greatest genocide in the
history.
Probably a million native americans died
in north America.
Ten millions died in south America.
Mainly through disease.
Yeah,
it's a.
It's the weirdest story.
If you stop and think about how quickly
it changed here in America,
in north America from the time the
columbus and you know from the,
the 14 hundreds to the,
you know,
the nIneteen hundreds or whatever today,
I mean it's an insane episode of
genocide
to be that way.
There's pretty good evidence that the
chinese came to the pacific coast and
even further down in maybe the early 14,
hundreds maybe earlier and they were
there to learn from the people to take
samples back to China.
They didn't and they didn't say,
this is going to be part of China.
We're going to make these people under
good buddhists.
They respected what they did and they
got their information and they'd sell it
back to China.
No,
the europeans who were there to brIng
people to the true religion,
they were there to trade,
to get gold,
to get mark,
to get first,
to enrich the old world At the expense
of the new work.
It is an amazing time though,
if you look,
if you look at a timeline,
like an animated timeline of the world
and then showed north America and north
America from the of the first europeans
and then this massive change that takes
place over this continent over the
course of the next several hundred
years,
gigantic cities just to rub the biggest
cities in the world has ever known
military complex builds up in nuclear
bombs,
start getting developed.
You know,
tHe internet airplanes,
all this shit happens in this one
continent.
I mean there's this one continent.
Essentially the last big continent to
get established by human beings becomes
the craziest motherfucker have.
Out of all.
You know,
it's.
It's really weird if you look at it from
a historical timeline,
the massive amount of impact that these
immigrants have had coming over from
europe and other parts of the world to
this one spot.
YeaH.
It could have happened a different way.
What we call Mexico city,
what they called a kyoto or calm or turn
up slot and Mexico.
That was a bigger city than london and
the sewers were clean.
The spaniards came.
They couldn't believe how clean the city
was,
and then of course they ruined it at
all.
How they ruined it,
they ruined it all because they wanted
gold and they took the spaniards ruined
it and they took botha zuma,
they a tortured him.
They killed him even though he filled a
room full of gold with them.
The same thing happened in Peru with
pizarro and whoa,
whoa,
whoa.
Here.
That,
there were these great empowers with
magnificent cities,
magnificent libraries.
THe mayan libraries were all burned to
the pieces.
We don't know the mayan wisdom because
the preset,
all of that,
this pagan stuff,
we have to get rid of it.
So there was a very,
very different mentality that as you
say,
completely changed things and then
things tend to start all over again.
It took a much different routes.
well,
the,
um,
the aztecs did some fucking crazy shit
themselves,
say sacrifice,
but at the same time,
the iNquisition in Spain and in Germany
and in parts of France and Italy,
we're also killing people by burning
them at the stake.
I don't let the aztec soft for the human
sacrifice,
but you know,
let's be fair.
Let's look what happens with the other
part of the world.
Yeah.
Didn't they sacrifice like,
I think over the course of like,
I'm going to look it up.
I think over the course of four days,
they sacrifice some insane number of
80,000
people.
Um,
the,
uh,
the pyramid of tea.
I don't know how to ican after they,
um,
in 14,
87 after the construction of it,
they sacrificed all the prisoners that
they use to make it 80,000
people who.
And one reason that they did all of the
sacrifices is they thought that the gods
were angry at them by bringing in the
spaniards and bringing in all of the
diseases started to kill people off.
So like I say,
no,
I'm not listening to the aztecs offer
the sacrifices.
That was a flaw in their civilization
that the very important for.
But they did create clean and beautiful
cities and they did have a forum
of government that work and they,
the artwork and the streets where you
mentioned the sewage,
they had sewer systems.
And they also had a,
the streets lit at night,
if I remember correctly,
three seats for the night and you're
going to lamps or something like that.
I don't know.
Do you know they weren't gas lamps for
sure.
Probably tortured,
but it was built.
It was an island in the middle of a big
lake and it only had like one or two
causeway.
So it was perfectly defendable.
But they'd invited cortez and his guys
in.
It was such a mess.
And one of the theories that you might
know more about this than I do,
but I'm the vikings came down to north
America much earLier,
like the 10th century or Something.
AnD one of the theories was that they
had gotten this far south as Mexico
because there was a myth that the.
There was a white god that came from the
east and said he'd returned someday.
And so when they found,
when the spanish showed up,
they're like,
ah,
you know,
it's the second coming.
Well,
the viking is of course are now
memorialized by the current tv series,
which is not bad by the way.
It's really.
And they just start the advice.
It's good.
Yup.
And the
kings had a very,
very important impact on not only
europe,
but yes,
they came and visited the north America.
they didn't kill off native american
indians.
They collaborated with them.
They learned from them.
They had their colonies.
Then things got a little too chilly and
cold and uncomfortable.
So they sailed back,
but they did not leave the legacy of
destruction and disease that the english
and the spaniards and the portuguese did
much later on.
And one interesting thing about the
white god legend is that when the core
cast came,
he came at just the right time.
The legend was the 30th day of the 30th
month,
the white god will come.
And so every time in that cycle that the
white god was supposed to come,
they had scouts on the gulf of Mexico
believable.
Not cortez came just when the prediction
was there and they welcomed him with
open arms.
I think it was one of the cruelest
coincidences,
the history of humankind that became a
just the right time.
So he was welcomed.
You think that's a coincidence though?
I'm,
I'm not into mysticism,
so I would say that that was either a
coincidence or else they got their facts
wrong.
Well,
you're not in the mysticism,
but yeah,
you are.
You are.
If you're talking about this psychic
dreaming,
that mystic,
I considered that quantum physics.
I think this is something that
ultimately be.
We'll be explainable in terms of enlarge
rural deal.
You don't think that there's a possible
connection that may be mean.
do you believe that there's a for the
world?
Do you believe that it's possible that
you know all these things that are
foretold that come to be true?
absolute bullshit.
One hundred percent bullshit.
I think that.
See,
I come from the point of view of
evolution,
watch adaptive watch.
Adaptive is not always for the best of
the world.
If we were to have an atomic bomb blast
who would adapt?
It would be the young sex.
Humans would be gone.
insects would be the ones who survive
because they could adapt.
They could withstand the atomic bomb.
Key points and key three.
My point though is that as you saw the
kennedy assassination in a in a psychic
vision,
is it possible that these people saw the
cortez in a psychic vision or who was
often referred to as a white beard in
god?
It was counseled people who according to
the legends sailed off into the gulf of
Mexico and said,
I will return around.
Just like douglas macarthur said,
I should've returned during the second
world war except capsule was a mythical
figure,
and again,
he he not only said that he would
return,
but the Legend SpecifieD when in the
cycle he would return.
Now that has this incredible coincidence
that I'm not going to explain.
I'm just going to point it out.
Yeah,
I mean,
I would think though that if you're
willing to consider the possibility that
you had this vision of kennedy,
he might consider the possibility of
long range visions that people,
these,
these aztecs and mayans are sitting
around taking mushrooms,
contemplating the future might have a
vision of these white men showing up.
Well,
why not?
Yellow time is a social construct and
native americans have the,
at least before the europeans arrived,
they had the concept of the long body
that our physical body is the short
body,
but the body extends into the future.
Now that long bodies can sometimes pick
up information from the future that it
brings back to the short body.
This is part of his metaphorical,
but to them it would be no surprise when
rolling thunder talked about global
warming and when he talked about
desertification and the pollution of the
air,
he was basing this on his observation of
what was going on,
but also he was going back to native
american prophecy.
I love that term.
Long body in short potty.
That's really fascinating.
Oh,
the native americans said all sorts of
concepts that are consistent with
quantum physics.
We devote a whole section of quantum
physics and our book about rolling
thunder,
the voice of rolling thunder and there
is an entire book called blackfoot
physics,
which takes the blackfoot indian tribe,
shows how closely their philosophy of
the earth corresponds to modern day
quantum physics.
So book by david pete,
who's a quantum physicist themselves,
what do they attribute the this,
this information from like the black
feet say,
how do they learn these concepts
passed down over the generations.
You can see some of it and the rock
carvings,
but mainly the myths and legends that
have been passed down.
Remember that most of the native
americans did not have a written
language.
The mayans had the very good rep
language,
but it didn't do them,
and you're good because the spaniards
berg,
all of their books and so this was
passed down from tribe to tribe,
from person to person from atlanta clan,
and you can see it today and the legends
that they talk about how the earth and
how the people in the earth are part of
a whole and how hard of a swerve a
change can have ripple effects that
affect the entire organism,
the entire family,
the entire clown,
the fire in the entire cosmos.
I'm also gonna talk about parallel
universes,
which was a quantum physics concept.
They talk about the upper world,
the lower world,
the middle earth.
I'm going to throw something out at you
and tell me if this makes any sense
because this is something that I've been
contemplating myself over the last few
years and that that's the idea that
human behavior,
even the most complex and in self
destructive of all human behavior is
natural and that like we see complex
social communities in wolf tribes and
wolf packs and with,
uh,
with various animals and we see the way
they interact and we say,
oh,
this is just nature.
This is the way to sort things out on a
much more complex scale.
Is it possible that all the self
destruction,
all the,
the crazy battles for resources that
we've seen in the world today,
that all of this is in fact just a
natural behavior pattern.
And it's literally the only way that
human beings exist in that this strange,
a contrast between massive amounts of
information being available and being
spread rapidly back and forth between
people and all these horrible injustices
that are all going on.
At the same time,
it's,
that's the yin and the yang of human
humanity.
That's a good way to put it.
This is the yin and the yang.
The balance.
People are neither good nor bAd.
They're both and the way that society
constructs their behavior,
conserve them one way or the other,
and also that like while we're doing
battle with these evils,
this is what propels innovation.
THis is what sort of propels people to
move forward.
That if we lived in some sort of a
utopian,
you know,
beautiful society of orgiastic love,
that maybe we'd never get anything done
and maybe that's part of what the human
animals here for in the first place,
like the aunt makes the ant hill.
The b makes the honeycomb,
the human being creates this uber
complex society,
one of the
mechanisms to ensure that society keeps
moving forth at this breakneck speed is
this conflict,
this constant conflict that's going on,
both social conflict,
economic conflict,
that all this is a part of this gigantic
ever complex natural behavior pattern.
It certainly is natural,
but don't overlook the other side of it.
When you go to darwin and read what he
had to say,
he uses terms like love cooperation,
collaboration much more often than he
uses conflict.
He sees this cooperation is what
engineers evolution and social progress.
He never used the word the words a
survival of the fittest.
Somebody else use that.
He didn't like that term.
He was more emphasis,
more empathetic,
um,
collaboration and even love.
Those are the words you find in his
books.
When I,
when I,
when I speak of these things,
when I'm,
what I'm saying is almost like as if I
was someone from another world,
if I was looking at the human race,
a completely objective,
lee and I'm looking at what one of these
crazy things doing and what direction
and if we were trying to study them and
trying to figure out what's causing all
this stuff to be taking place at the
same time,
I almost would would look at it that
way.
Then it's like maybe it's,
this is really complex natural behavior
that's moving towards some sort of.
It means seems to be some sort of
technological integration.
I mean it seems to be that that's what's
the number one push.
If we look at where it,
what people are doing with innovation,
with technology at all seems to be a
connection between humans and
technology.
This symbiotic connection,
oh,
this is a soul called singularity that
you hear so much about where are the
humans and the technological innovations
are going to combine into a singular
society or even a singular organism who
knows and that might be adaptive.
That might be a direction that humans
couldn't go.
And so I think you're on the right
track.
I think that this is a very innovative
way of thinking,
but let's talk about practicality and
the listeners of your show at quite have
to decide,
okay,
which side of history are you going to
be on?
Are you going to be on the side that
the,
uh,
full mount suicide bombing and religious
bigotry or you're going beyond the side,
the facilitates love and human
cooperation and care for children and
women and men.
Which side is better?
Strip club,
which side has better strip clubs as the
side of religious
collaboration.
They have the better strip clubs up
there on the side of beauty there on the
side of love.
No doubt about it.
Yeah.
That's where you want to leave.
What were you going to say?
I was just gonna say when you're in
your,
your point,
they're talking
about how to what extent this is natural
human behavior.
Keep in mind that anatomically modern
human beings are.
Most scientists would say about 200,000
years on the planet.
Right?
And until very until the last couple of
hundred or a thousand,
depending on how you want to look at it.
They were living the same way forever
and you know,
like 40,000
years you'd get boeing arrow instead of
spheres,
you know,
that would be the one technological
advance,
you know,
and,
and so there's been a lot of debate like
what happened,
why wasn't there more movement and
progress and all this stuff.
And at the moment the best theory I know
of is that people were comfortable.
There wAsn't any need necessity.
The mother of invention.
Right?
So like there's plenty of food around
blending.
You look at,
you know,
how many hours hunter gatherer people
spend working compared to us.
They work a lot less than we do.
So,
you know,
I,
I see your point and I agree with,
with what you're saying and the
singularity,
I think we're definitely going in that
direction,
but to say that it's a natural human
behavior,
we have to keep in mind that it's been a
quantum shift in the very last seconds
of human existence.
Isn't that sort of like almost like the
rosetta stone.
Like we figured out how to make metal
and then we figured out how to conduct
electricity and then we're off to the
races and we just like,
we put a couple of things together,
the key pieces in the language of
technology and that set off this,
but there's intentionality there.
You're,
you're attributing.
Whereas I think it's a happenstance.
I think it's a question of a population
densiTy that we didn't ever choose.
That's a quick.
I get the question all the time,
like if agriculture sucks so bad,
why did we do it?
As if we,
you know,
some guys were like,
hey,
why don't we start farming,
you know,
they wiLl,
will make a deal.
It happens.
I'm reminded of this guy.
This happened.
You might have known about this in
sonoma.
There were some,
uh,
there at a winery and um,
there's some tourIsts,
they're getting ready to take balloon
rides over the winery and they were
setting up one of the balloons,
hot air balloons and,
and it started to pull away and the
balloon guys were having trouble
managing it.
And a german tourist who was standing
there ran over to help them and grab the
basket of the balloon and then the
balloon took off.
It broke free.
And if you're a professional working
with balloons,
you never let both your feet off the
ground.
That's like the rule.
If you're working with balloons once,
both feet leave the ground,
you let go.
This guy didn't know that.
So what happened?
He went up,
he hung on as long as he could.
Then he fell.
All his friends watching,
he couldn't pull himself up in the
parking lot.
Oh fuck.
Can't fight mother nature.
You can't fight gravity,
so that's,
that's how I see at the advent of
agriculture is like,
you know,
it made sense at the time and then you
get tied into the loop.
You can't get out,
but
isn't that sort of the same pattern of
complexity?
It's we,
we figure
out one thing that integrates us more
deeply wIth each other and then from
there that innovation leads to more
innovations which lead to bigger
buildings which lead to,
you know,
different irrigation methods which lead
to larger supplies of food which leads
to more people,
which leads to more innovation because
there's more people which leads to
communication issues,
which leads to the invention of phones,
which I mean it's,
it's this constant technological
progression.
Yes,
technical logical progression,
but along with that comes pollution
comes.
Desertification comes global warming.
That's the dark side,
but is that necessary?
Is that not more of the yin and yang
like the the solution needs to be
acquired,
like someone needs to figure out a way
to have a sustainable sort of an urban
environment like instead of this idea
where we're constantly burning fossil
fuels,
there's other ways to extract energy.
Why do not?
Why?
Why don't we have solar cities?
We don't have.
Why don't?
Why isn't los angeles solar city?
You want to talk about the dumbest
fucking thing ever.
Fly over downtown la.
Everybody's operating on coal,
power to electricity and this fucking
sunlight everywhere.
Three hundred and 60 days a year.
it it rains for days a year out here and
there's no solar panels anywhere in
downtown la.
When I was at the university of
Wisconsin back in the early 19 fifties
while of our chemistry professors was
preaching soLar power and nobody
believed him,
they thought he waS off the wall anD he
even had invented solar panels,
which other people had founded.
Also,
solar panels and solar power had been
with us potentially since the late
forties or early 19 fifties,
but they were a threat to establishment
govern reliance on fossil fuels.
Now,
so only now Are we waking up,
well,
we'd better go in that direction if
we're going to avoid the destruction of
the earth and most people still don't
give that high priority,
so the knowledge was there,
but they were bypassed.
Well,
like the electric car,
you know what happened to the original
car?
It just ran a foul of commercial
interests,
so a lot of these innovations that could
have led to sustainability long time ago
were bypassed and only now,
maybe before it's too late,
can we go back and bring those into
fruition.
That brings us back to what we were
talking about earlier with the hemp and
the original issue with him being that
hemp as a commodity where Henry Ford
made the first body panels,
have a car.
They were made out of hemp.
His car also ran on hemp fuel and this
is the very first cars that Henry Ford
created,
and that's very little known fact that
camp in in a fiber form when they turn
it into body panels is actually stronger
and Lighter than Steel.
Oh,
hampers wonDerful.
George Washington grew hemp by the way,
and no,
you try
to get government subsidies for hamp.
you even tried to get legal permission
to grow hemp and you run up against a
brick wall.
Well,
we own a part of a supplement company
and one of the thIngs that we sell is
hemp protein powder and we have to buy
it from Canada.
We can't grow it in the United States.
We have to buy it from Canada and it's
very popular and we can only get 50
pounds a day from these people because
of the fact that it's so.
It's so much in demand.
It's really hard to to keep keep up with
the demand and we.
There's been laws passed and because
Colorado and Washington state both
passed laws legalizing marijuana,
they also are trying to legalize hemp
farming,
but even though hemp is non
psychoactive,
they're still facing a massive backlash
from the federal government and people
are scared to pull the trigger and start
farming.
Even just hemp,
just just fArming him,
which is non psychoactive.
Again,
the cousin of the marijuana plant,
you can't.
You'll go to jail,
they'll lock you up in a cage for
growing a plant that's perhaps the most
spectacular plant available to human
beings on the planet earth today.
Yeah,
it's the plant with the longest,
a verified cultivation.
It's the first thing humans ever
cultivated as far as we know.
Isn't that like the best sign that we're
crazy like that?
That's illegal.
I mean it's one of the best signs that
we've
politically last script.
The rational.
I mean on top of everything the
government does is out of money.
I mean,
tours of the white house are being
curtailed.
A flowers for the tomb of the unknown
soldieR are not being placed and because
of these stupid little budget cuts,
why can't we grow hemp and tax it?
Why caN't we grow marijuana and tax it?
Just think of the tax revenues that
would come in.
You have all the money that wouldn't go
to the drug warriors.
Is it shocking for you to have lived
this long and seen us go from the
fifties to 2013 and see where we're at
today?
Did you think that we'd be much further
along by now?
No.
I have always been very much of a
realist and I have never been a utopian.
I just sort of take what comes.
I have seen human folly in one form or
another and I've certainly come to some
human folly myself,
so I'm just made of course and I'm
disappointed,
but I wouldn't say I'm shocked.
If you could address the people of the
world and urge them to move in one
direction or the other.
What what,
what do you think would be the best
method for change for this world?
Good heavens.
I would never reach that pinnacle of
publicity or success or egotism,
but what comes to mind most quickly
would say,
be a little kinder to each other,
be a lot kinder to each other.
Right.
If I were a little more enthusiastic,
I would say it'd be a lot kinder,
less enthusiastic.
What holds you back?
I would go one step at a time.
Starting a liTtle kinder works and
viola.
Yeah,
and that's a psychedelic state of mind,
isn't it?
I mean,
that's a psychedelic ideology.
Yeah.
I.
that's one thing I've most certainly
Learned from my experiences is that
there's some sort of a strange
connection between human beings and when
we exercise that connection to,
or I should say,
when we respect that connection,
honor that connection.
It enhances the way you feel about life
and enhancers to being kind to other
people has a positive effect on you as
an individual.
It's like the universe reinforcing that
sort of behavior.
Well,
this really ties together matraville
talking about,
we're talking about shamanism and our
book justifying shamans,
shamans help the community be kind to
each other,
help the community work together.
Shamans in terms like rolling thunder
saw the need for communities all over
the world who work together.
Politicians haven't quite gotten that
message yet.
And the psychedelic ethos,
if you want to call it that,
is one of connectivity is one of
kindness.
It's one of seeing the hologram and
which we all live.
It's interesting,
the shamans and the,
the term shamanism,
almost all of it comes from much smaller
populations.
And uh,
I think that may be a key to the issue
is that we went in reaching like New
York city,
los angeles,
you,
these 10 million,
20 million city populations,
you almost,
there's almost too many people to
manage.
And the term shaman or the idea of a
showman gets very weird when you're in a
tribe of a few hundred people and you
have one trusted man that you've known
your whole life.
You know his chAracter.
You know what he's really all about.
He's not,
he's not trying to run some jim jones
bullshit and start his own cult.
But when you,
when you have a million people and you
have 10 million people,
whatever you have,
and you start calling yourself a shaman
and you gather up a following and they
come from all around,
next thing you know you've got a cult.
This is why you don't cAll yourself a
shaman.
A community appoints you a shaman.
If you call yourself a shaman,
then you get into the whole cult
mentality and you know what happens to
cults?
Usually they get out of hand and they
elude to lead to the jim jones
phenomenon.
The mass suicide.
Yeah.
Is it possible to avoid that?
Can you have a nice cold?
Is that something that people never
figured out?
Like,
look,
they didn't even figure out the airplane
until the 18 hundreds.
Right?
Is it possible to figure out a nice
colt?
I don't think you'd call it a cult
because the word called has taken on a
negative connotation.
Right?
But it doesn't have to be.
I think you could have a nice cold.
I'd have to strange biomet,
straighten my imagination to think of
one.
But,
uh,
I would suppose a.
Theoretically it's possible.
Well,
I caught the quakers were not really a
cult because they never had a primary
leader.
A so called assumes that personality at
the center of it.
Okay.
Does it have to?
Well,
that's the definition of cold focuses on
a person.
You could.
Well,
I,
I hear a talk about the grateful dead
cult now that certainly has been very
beneficial during the era that the
grateful dead were wrong with all of the
deadheads and even though you had some
people going off the edge at grateful
dead concerts,
bottled large was a loving,
collaborative,
cooperative group.
And the grateful dead singers themselves
certainly didn't preach violence and
terrorism.
They preached love and peace and joy and
happiness.
And you hear in the music that's called
a cult.
I would not use that term myself,
but uh,
that had a,
not one person but a group of people at
the head of it.
And when the grateful dead ended,
well you have the memories linger on and
the members of the great how all doing
useful and beautiful and artistic things
on their own.
Burning man.
Yeah.
That sort of thing.
Have you been to
burning man?
Yes.
Oh,
you've been there.
I have bounced or something like
burningham burn burning man.
I've built a,
one of the smaller venues,
but I don't think that you had called
out a cult because that doesn't focus
around a Particular person.
I would call that a social movement,
a social phenomenon.
I,
uh,
I could get down with the whole grateful
dead thing set the music sucks.
A kiss cam.
Oh,
that's a matter of taste.
I'm only fucking around,
but I have a degree
filled.
They'll have their own archive.
It was not their idea,
but the university of California,
santa cruz opened up an archive now that
I was there for the ground debut of the,
uh,
of the collection.
And they're doing a marvelous Job in
terms of showing the whole chronology of
what they called the grateful dead
phenomenon.
Add tHat the such a mosaic with knoll
denier movement at all.
It's a challenge to put that into what's
going to be 24 rooms and they have
gotten donations literally from all over
the world and they've arranged it very,
veRy tastefully.
This is open to the public and there you
can get a real taste of what a social
Movement can do,
an artistic movement.
Also the how it can start and what that
lead to.
Yeah,
the.
I think that in that it was a very
positive movement and the dad sort of
emphasized peace and love and that
everybody would go around.
My cousin actually follow the debt
around for years and years and her and
her boyfriend used to sell eggs and
bacon from the back of their car.
They had like a little grill and they
would cook and the concerts and feed
people and make beads and shit and do
weird crafts and stuff and she was a
full on deadhead for several years.
Just followed them from venue to venue
and that's a.
I don't know how that happens.
How does a band like that that happens
for them,
but it doeSn't happen for the rolling
stones.
It happens for,
you know,
it's,
it's a strange thing.
That's the merry pranksters,
right?
They were the house band for ken keyes.
Ease.
She had a great deal to do with it.
Right.
And they used to go around in the bus
right onwards and uh,
they would go from town to town and do
the,
what they Call it,
the electric koolaid acid test,
so they would have concerts where they
were alsO passing out acid,
so they'd like pull into some town in
Nebraska or something,
You know,
find a big field somewhere and everybody
would come out,
there'd be acid and the grateful dead
would play.
So the,
from the very beginning,
the altered consciousness was part of
the musical experience.
Wolfe's book,
the electric koolaid acid test is really
a very good chronology.
And you didn't have other bands who had
a key sheet sort of adopt them as a
vehicle for his own creativity.
Yeah.
Did you ever meet ken keyes?
Yes,
I did.
I've met volunteered girl who was the
significant other of both Kentucky kishi
and of Jerry Garcia monitoring girl was
there for the debut of the archives.
And her daughter is the one who on jerry
garcia's dog or cut the ribbon to open
the archives.
No,
that's a very important part of the
history.
Mountain girl was Jerry Garcia.
And ken keyes,
his girlfriend at the same time?
No.
A space between the two.
There's a little bit of gap.
Who got her first?
I think that Jerry Garcia was Jerry
Garcia.
How many shifts have you been to
[inaudible]?
I've been to two,
but I'm sure you've been to hundreds of
grateful dead shows.
Oh,
not hundreds.
You got to remember that I had a full
time job at the time and I had a family
to take care of.
I estimate high to at least 50 years.
Wow.
15 grateful dead shows and yet still can
hold a conversation.
Say folks not propaganda has been
mainly at the shows,
but he was onstage and finally yesterday
he was telling me,
sitting behind the drum drummers,
looking out in one concert,
a guy comes,
sits down next to him.
It's david byrne.
Whoa.
FIrst day,
first time David Burnett ever been to a
dead show.
And you were his guy to educate david
byrne about the grateful dead so that he
could have an educated conversation with
them after the show.
Did you ever do any psychedelics with
dolphins or did you ever experiment with
that?
Swim with dolphins,
but I've never done psychedelics with
dolphins.
Not not necessarily being with dolphins
as a high enough experience on
themselves.
Did you know john lilly?
Yes.
I knew him very well.
Yeah.
Lily had some fascinating experiments
with dolphins and psychedelics acid and
the tanks.
Sensory deprivation tanks.
AbsoluTely.
Did you get involved in the tank at all?
Sensory deprivation.
Separate deficit.
I've done sensory deprivation tanks in
the lots of psychedelics because they
had experiences good enough in and of
itself.
A lot of the experiences that I like in
and of themselves and I don't need them
to be augmented by psychedelics.
Yeah,
I agree with that with the sensory
deprivation tank,
but I think it takes a little while to
get get the hang of yes to relax and
learn how to let go in there and really
find those altered states of
consciousness.
I've had several people talk to me.
I'm like,
oh,
I tried to tank a couple times that I
really didn't trip my balls off.
I'm like,
wow,
okay.
You're not.
Maybe I've described this running.
I don't to be to town talented here,
but when I enter into these experiences,
I do it with what chris just called
intentionality on us.
Okay,
well,
how am I going to learn from this
experience?
What am I going to take away from this
experience that is beneficial to me,
my friends and the world at large.
Every time I've taken iowasca,
I've written the what I've learned and I
have gotten a very important lesson from
each of my town iowasca sessions.
The last session was so powerful.
I'm still learning from him,
still trying to put louis lessons into
practice.
How long ago was that?
That was a year and a half ago.
Year and a half ago,
and it was so powerful.
You're still trying to
absorb it.
Brazil.
Very,
very powerful.
What is the most profound thing you've
learned from psychedelic experiences
if you had a most?
I.
I try not to play favorites because I've
learned so much,
but if you put me on the spot,
I would say that human beings are not a
part from nature.
Human beings are part of nature,
and when human being separate themselves
from the rest of nature,
they run a mock,
they get into trouble,
so living a natural life with the
principles of nature of all of our
relations is the way,
not only to a happy life,
but a fulfilling life and the meaningful
life.
Do you think that our current state of
ignorance,
when it comes to that,
is just a byproduct of us expanding from
the world of primitive hominids to
language,
to explaining feelings and thoughts,
to eventually understanding the full
spectrum of our impact in the world.
You've put up very well and I'd like to
put
that into the context of neuroscience
and the brain.
We've gotten ourselves into a situation
where the western consciousness is
focused in the frontaL lobeS anD in part
of the left hemisphere of the brain.
We ignore The reptilian brain,
the medulla oblongata,
the spinal cord.
we ignore the penalty.
All mammalian brain,
the limbic system where the emotions
come in.
We've even,
if you ignore the right hemisphere,
except for lefthanded people,
the right hemisphere is the holistic
hemisphere where we see things as a
whole.
There's a complete gestalt.
We are focused in the left hemisphere,
which again,
for everybody,
but the lefthanded people,
we can't leave them out there a little
bit different.
Focuses on linear thinking,
on bits and parts and pieces,
on reason,
on down,
on rational approaches to stuff,
and we leave out imagination,
intuition,
emotion,
all of the things that make a person
fuLly human.
Yeah.
That'S a very,
very important point.
You know,
I,
I think that science is an amazing
aspect of our worlD and our ability to
measure nature and understand the very
just the building blocks of,
of reality is really amazing stuff.
BuT one of the things that science can
account for his love can account for
appreciation of art can account for the
way you feel when a great song comes on.
The radio,
you know,
can account for the,
the,
the beauty of a person's personality.
So certain people that are just amazing
to be around that you see them,
you smile.
It's like there's this immeasurable
connection to passion and love that that
human being share that's again to
measurable,
you know,
you can't quantiFy,
you can't write it down.
You can't,
and it's one of the most important
aspects of humanity.
It is.
I'm going to put in a plug for saybrook
university beCause you are trying to
expand the boundaries of science and say
that there can be art based science,
there can be love based science where
people can use narratives to describe
their experience route,
can use neuroscience to figure out
what's going on in the brain,
the gut,
the heart and the body and that's not
going to completely explain all of this
because you have to depend upon
literature and the arts and poetry and
painting to do justice to it,
but at least we could do much more than
we've done in the past with very narrow
conceptions of science
and in teaching in saybrook university,
you said that the courses were all
available online,
so people from anywhere in the world
listening to this
sign.
Of course they have to pay for the
courses and register with you.
Well,
it depends upon the course.
I would say people can go to our
website,
saybrook.edu,
when they'll get the whole.
How do you spell saybrook?
S a y,
b r o o k saybrook.edu.
Yes.
And they can find on how much everything
costs.
They can.
I handle a course on actually a
certificate course that anybody can take
on the psychology of dreams and dreaming
repeat after laurel how to work with
dreams and learn the brain science
behind dreams and dreaming.
So there you have both the cycle neuro
cycle,
neurology of dreams and the neuroscience
of dreams.
But you have the art of dreams,
the interpretation of dreams,
the dreams make with the rest of the
body and with the significant people
around you.
What about the connection between dreams
and the body's endogenous production of
how senate,
like
dmt,
like rick strassman's work on,
uh,
on,
on dmt,
aware of us?
Yes.
Rick strauss would be great.
Another great pie in your,
you know,
all the important people.
I'm very,
very impressed.
Oh,
he's amazing.
He's a good friend.
I love that guy in his book,
dmt.
The spirit molecule is one in one of the
most important books I've ever read.
The,
uh,
the brain.
Well,
we don't really,
I mean the law,
everyone likes to say the pineal gland
produces dmt and there's some anecdotal
evidence to that,
but we know bob just forget about where
it's produced.
We know it's made in the body.
We know absolutely it exists in the
human boDy aNd thAt it's one of the most
transient substances known demand,
meaning that when you take dmt in,
especially in a smokable form,
your body brings you back to baseline
extremely quickly.
And one of The weird things about the
dmt experiences that it has a very
similar effect to dream states in that
they're very vivid immediately after the
experience,
but then shortly after just like a
dream,
you're like,
god,
what happened?
What was it?
And it's almost in my humble estimation,
like a protection mechanism,
like your,
your,
your reality,
the material world,
knocking on things,
weighing things.
That reality is,
it's so hard to combine the two,
the hallucinogenic reality,
the dmt reality is so bizarre that it's
almost like the brands like,
listen,
bitch,
you can't handle this.
We're just going to erase that shit for
you.
You know?
You know what I mean?
How can you have.
I mean,
I've had many dmt trips in the most
vivid ones.
They're so incredibly powerful right
after it happens,
but they're gone within five minutes.
You have to.
If you don't record it,
if you don't write it down,
it's like most of the experience somehow
or another slips out of your fingers.
Well,
of
course,
shifting from one type of conscious to
suit other type of consciousness is
difficult.
You're going to forget what you did.
This is why when people wake up from the
dream,
if they don't try to found right away
there,
we're going to forget it,
and even though they don't remember the
entire dream.
One nice thing about dreams.
This involves the whole brain.
This is why shamanism is so closely
linked with dreams.
Shamanism.
The shaman uses the whole brain,
the shaman through drugs,
through dreams,
through dancing,
through drumming,
etc.
Uses parts of the brain that other
people in the community do not use and
in dreams you've got the emotions,
you've got the reflexes,
you've got these survival mechanisms and
you've got the transcendent experiences
all in one neat little package and if
you don't write that stuff down and put
it to use,
you're going to forget it.
I do that all the time.
I've been in bed and I have this
hilarious idea and like,
oh,
I'm not going to forget that one.
And I wake up in the morning and justin
bieber.
What about justin bieber all the time,
right?
It drives me nuts.
Since the nineties I've been carrying
these little recorders,
these digital voice recorders because of
that.
Yeah,
and that's been the bed every night
under my pilloW sometimes because you
just hit the button.
You don't even have to wake up.
Yeah,
I'm going to have to start doing that
because I record everything on my
iphone,
but then you got to open the iphone.
Going to apps and the digital recording
these things.
Some of them you just plug it into the
computer and it transfers it into text,
right?
Yeah.
So yeah,
transfers it into text so you don't have
to listen and decide.
That's a good one.
That's a bad way.
You just get a list.
Yeah,
that's a new thing.
I didn't know that.
That's good.
Oh wow.
That's a beautiful thing.
Yeah.
Have you seen any of that?
A voice to text software?
I've seen that a lot.
I'd like to put it to use.
I think it's a great advance.
Want to see something called watch.
I'll show it to you right now.
This is how amazing these things are.
This is just a regular iphone.
When you go into the notes application,
when you go into the notes application
and you want to make a note to get this
little thing right here,
that looks like a microphone.
When you press that and you go,
stanley kripner is a bad motherfucker,
and then he'd be like that a butchered.
You said stanley crypt.
There is a bad motherfucker.
And then.
oh,
because I said,
oh yeah,
well I trained it and trained it from
motherfucker,
but that's pretty good,
so I bet you would do it again.
Dr.
Christopher Ryan is a bad motherfucker.
There you go.
Dr.
Christopher Ryan is a bad motherfucker.
Perfect.
I have proof.
Proof is there in the notes.
Yeah.
That must be an amazing thing to have
witnessed,
to see people going from textbooks to
the internet to and to be able to hold a
studies and to hold classes online.
That's true.
This is why should you?
Morning star and I worked so well
together on their book,
the voice of rolling thunder because he
wants to round with his ipod,
interviewing people and he has his own
website,
open source religion,
which you're williston should plug into
where people from different religious
persuasions can come to a website and
argue things out and discuss things on
the internet without even meeting each
other physically.
Some people from various ideologies can
compare noTes as to who's crazier.
That's a kind way of putting it.
When you see like in them,
after all you've been through it.
When you see the shit that's going down
with this,
well,
we have a new pope.
Oh,
and everybody lines up and all the major
media and the news,
they treat it like it's a real event.
It's really mind boggling.
You got a guy dressed up like a wizard
who runs a,
a whole clan of kid fuckers and they're
taking it seriously.
How come jerry,
if jerry sandusky had been religiously
ordained,
would he not be in prison now?
They would sneak them around.
They would move him somewhere with that
guy.
One of the reasons why they had to get
rId of the pope for folks who don't know
is that the pope is responsible.
The past pope,
not the new one.
The past pope was responsible for having
a man released who molested over 200
deaf kids.
200.
He took him.
I'm shielded him from prosecution and
then moved to a new parish where he
molested more kids.
I mean,
it's a huge,
huge scandal and you're right.
If jerry sandusky hadn't been involved
in the religion of football,
but instead was involved in religion of
catholicism,
you're very right.
I bet he would be,
he would be afraid.
There's a lot of people that are free
right now.
Just be shifted to another team.
Yeah.
Well,
one of the things they've done is they
take people and they,
they say they're punishing them by
removing them from,
from churches,
and they bring them to these gigantic
religious compounds when they have these
beautiful grounds and his place in North
Carolina where they took this,
uh,
this guy who was responsible for
molesting dozens of kids.
You know,
it's like they're criminAls.
These horrible,
horrible criminals and somehow or
another we tolerate it.
It's really a weird aspect of our modern
culture and give them tax rate.
Yeah,
free free zero taxes if you're in the
cult.
I mean,
well,
do you know Alex Gray?
Well,
alex grey is a,
he's got his whole chapel.
That was a brilliant,
brilliant guy and a beautiful human
being.
It's just a really loving.
He was so funny we had on the podcast,
anytime I'd say anything negative about
anything,
he just like,
well,
you have to.
He would always find the positive loving
side and not criticizing anyone.
I'm like a joke and I'm a comedian,
man,
I don't really mean this.
That's stanley stanley's the same way.
And so over the years I was standing and
I have known each other 20 years or
something and you know,
a lot.
We talk about sex a lot,
you know,
we spent a lot of time on the road,
he's talking about sex and it sadly to
say,
oh,
I want to introduce you to so
and so.
She's so beautiful and I'm thinking
stanley stanley things.
Everyone's beautiful.
It's a beautiful thing.
Well,
you take in terms of,
you know,
beautiful in spirit,
but alex great is a wonderful artist,
but one of the reasons he's such a
wonderful artist,
he does take a very positive,
optimistic view of people and of life
and that shows up in his art and I think
his art is spiritual.
It's fantastic.
I think he's,
you know,
historically very important and I've
been impressed with his art from the
beginning and his wife,
his wife is equally talented.
Those wonderful work.
yeah,
she,
she was with him when he came in into
the podcast.
He's a true visionary artists in the
sense that he,
in my opinion,
is he has the most accurate
representations of the tryptamine world.
Like in painted form.
Like I,
when I look at his paintings,
I see like tripping.
I see like there's one of 'em,
it's a gold one.
It looks like to faroe heads,
like there are facing in opposite
directions.
Like I literally,
it seems like something that you would
see if you were a,
you were on dmt painting,
brilliant,
brilliant artist.
He is actually achieved a tax exempt
status because this chapel,
the sacred mirrors,
his,
uh,
his religion is actually being
recognized as a true religion.
Wow.
Yeah.
It's really interesting because he's in
sort of a,
like locally,
they don't want to recognize it.
Like they want the tax money from him
and he's like,
well listen though,
I'm a religion,
like I am tax exempt and if the
methodists are tax exempt and the
catholics at tasks,
why,
why not the chapel,
the sacred marriage.
And you know,
he's like sort of duking it out with
these people in his area because they
want,
they want the money.
They want to capture that in brooklyn.
No,
he um,
he had,
he was in manhattan for awhile and then
he,
uh,
he moved his place to upstate New York
and he's constructing this incredible
compound where the balls and the
building of it are all his art,
like his fractal sort of geometric
artwork is going to be what the entire
outside of the building looks like me.
He showed us some of the plans and it's,
it's amazing some of his art right
there.
It's just amazing,
amazing stuff.
And,
and in my opinion,
the most accurate in terms of capturing
that,
that those visionary experiences,
those house and hallucinogen based
experiences,
he's the most accurate in doing that.
He did a poRtrait of my dear friend
Albert Hoffman.
Yes.
That the love the style on the cover of
a new biography of off.
Yes.
I love that picture.
You know,
brian and see if he could pull up that
picture of Albert Hoffman that he did.
That's a,
that's a brilliant
picture.
Albert hoffman,
the guy who first isolated lsd.
Um,
yeah.
The guys like Alex Gray.
You see that vision,
you see that artwork and he makes you
want to try those drugs.
Like he,
he makes you want to like,
man,
I want to see that.
You know what the father's.
Yeah.
That's an amazing,
amazing pictures.
Shamanically a representation of him
too.
Absolutely.
And as long as albert doesn't call
himself a shaman or.
Okay.
Right.
He's got one of obama,
so that's just ridiculous.
Alex needs to go read about drones.
So alex's Wife wasn't pulling a yoko on
you.
That's good to know.
No,
she sat down during the whole thing.
she let him talk the entire time.
Scream.
Why does she,
uh,
she yoko occasionally.
No,
I just can't get that thing out.
Yeah.
Well,
I always said negative opinion of yoko
or at least not a positive one,
but that one just made me howl.
That's so great.
Well listen,
stanley,
thank you very much for joining us.
This has been a really fun time and I
really enjoyed it.
It was a real honor to get to sit down
and talk to you.
Sure.
I learned a lot from our discussion.
I learned a lot from you.
Is there anything you'd like to say to
the young folks out there,
the people that are in charge of moving
this thing to the next era,
if you will,
you're.
You're getting to talk to more than a
million people right now.
What would you say that.
No,
we've been talking a lot about about,
about psychedelics,
and I'd like to remind people that
that's only one way to gain wisdom
that's not necessary.
You can do just about the same thing by
immersing yourself in nature,
by having a loving relationship with
somebody,
by meditating,
by praying,
by immersing yourself in great
literature and great art.
Psychedelics are important.
They were important in human evolution,
but there's no one way.
There's no one road that's best for
everybody.
Yoga,
meditation,
transcendental meditation,
sensory deprivation tank use.
There's a lot of different methods to
sort of reset yourself and get an
objective look at the surroundings where
you're not caught up in the momentum of
your.
Exactly.
The important thing is to do this with
intentionality,
to know where you're going in,
to do it in a disciplined way and learn
something from it,
and one of the coolest things about this
life is that we get to meet and talk to
people that have lived longer and then
have had more experiences and it's
beautiful that a person like you is
willing to share those experiences and
come on a show like this and express
yourself and give us the wisdom of your
years and give us the insight of all
your,
your contemplations on this world.
I really appreciate it,
man.
Very kind of you and very kind of you to
say nice things about the voice of
rolling thunder and justifying shamans
or you can get these books.
Are they're available on amazon?
Are they available on audible.com?
No,
no,
not yet.
Okay.
Well we got to work with audible and
find some do to.
Who would you like to read these?
Maybe duncan trussell.
He'd be the perfect guy.
Do you know dunkin?
I know of him,
yeah.
Would you like to.
If we come to san francisco,
would you do a podcast with dan?
We're coming to you next.
You came to us.
We will come to you.
One other book that I have to mention
because I'm in the middle of it right
now and I fucking love and he's right
here.
Christopher ryan sex at dawn.
We had him here this week,
but you can't have enough fucking
awesome dude.
And your book's amazing.
So demystifying shamans in their world.
That is one book,
the voice of rolling thunder.
That is another book.
How many books you have out.
You have a gang of books.
I have 10 books out.
They're all available on amazon.
Fresh.
Beautiful,
powerful stanley creditor.
Thank you sir.
Really appreciate it
coming on here.
All right,
thank you everybody for tuning into the
podcast.
We will be back next week.
We have,
uh,
some,
some interesting guests next week on
monday we have brian cowen and tuesday
we have doug douglas rushkoff,
who's a brilliant author as well.
Can't wait to talk to that man.
That's going to be a really interesting
conversation.
Thanks to hover for sponsoring this
episode of the podcast,
if you go to hover.com
forward slash brogan,
you will get 10 percent off your domain
name registrations.
Go there,
check it out,
and be well.
Thanks.
Also to audible.com.
If you go to audible.com
forward slash joe,
you will get one free audio book and 33
days of audible service,
a a brilliant service and one in which
you can get sex at dawn,
read by some other asshole,
but at least Christopher Ryan gives the
monkey story.
At least it gives you that.
Thanks also to [inaudible] dot com.
If you go to o,
n n I t use a codename rogan,
you will save yourself 10 percent of any
and all supplements.
I do not know.
People keep asking me if any of the a
chimpanzee kettlebells are still
available.
We only were able to make a thousand of
them.
People like,
well,
is it limited to people with their
money?
Everyone.
So negative.
Listen folks,
it's a piece of art.
These kettlebells,
it's hard.
We had to create a mold.
We had a hire an artist.
We had to get this turned into this
functional piece of exercise equipment
and it's not that easy to do so we can
only get a thousand made in our first
order.
We're not trying to hold you back.
We want to sell as many of them as
possible and yes,
we have more common.
We've got a gorilla common.
We've got a the zombies.
We got some crazy shit headed.
I don't want to tell you anymore.
Go to [inaudible] dot com.
Oh,
and it codename rogan.
Save yourself some cash off any of the
supplements and We will see you people
on monday.
Thanks everybody.
Came to the ice house last night.
We had a great fucking time.
As always.
We love the shit out of you.
we'll see you soon.
Big kiss
the.